LET ME. A FACTS WHEN THEY- OF
THE PROCESS IN AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN RE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE AND CAPITAL WITH SOME
MEMBERS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY TODAY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE OUR PRESIDENT
AND HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM.
BY THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE THROUGH COMPUTERS
IT'LL GREATLY AID IN
ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I S. IT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED AS
SHE USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
HOW ARE I. T. PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE
YOUR NAME. AND THEN YOUR READY
TO ADDRESS THE SUB COMMITTEE.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE
ORIGINATED. A MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE- INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. OR BACKUP
HEARING ROOM IS ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BUT FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE CA PUBLIC
COMMENT AND JUST TO BE CLEAR WE
HAVE FOUR ITEMS TODAY AND WE
WILL BE TAKING PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ALL FOUR AFTER WE HEAR THE
FOURTH SIDE- THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS- POSTED ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
ONE OUNCES NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT FOUR
FOUR TWO NINE ONE. 585-844-2914
ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. 338-046-7338. ZERO
FOUR SIX SEVEN FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
ARE ONCE AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE ON
THE TELECONFERENCES TO. FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU WERE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE OUR
MAIN TO MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING QUITE HAVE
THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS. IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME
LIGHT TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
WHO ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW
USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT. SO ALL
MORE INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. AND IT'LL BE SUCH A
THRILL WHEN WE GO BACK TO IN
PERSON BECAUSE I'M TOSSING
DESCRIPT IN THE TRASH WHEN THAT
HAPPENS- FROM. TODAY'S HEARING
WILL COVER A VARIETY OF ISSUES
UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION INCLUDING SCHOOL
NUTRITION STUDENT ASSESSMENTS
AND STATE OPERATIONS. ARE NO
VOTES WILL BE TAKEN TODAY IN
PUBLIC COMMENT AS I SAID
EARLIER WE AT THE END OF THE
HEARING ONCE WE'VE COMPLETED
ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS. TO PUT
THIS HEARING INTO CONTEXT WE
HAD A HEARING SINCE FEBRUARY
THE EIGHTH WAS ON MARCH FIRST.
TO HEAR MOST OF THE MAJOR
ISSUES THAT ARE IN. THE PURVIEW
OF THE SUB COMMITTEE WE'RE
HAVING THIS HEARING TODAY WE
WILL HAVE ANOTHER HEARING NEXT
WEDNESDAY WE WILL HAVE A JOINT
HEARING WITH THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ON
THURSDAY. AND WHEN THAT'S DONE
WE WILL HAVE HEARD EVERY ISSUE
THAT IS IN THE BUDGET THEN ONCE
THE MAY REVISE COMES OUT WE
WILL HAVE A HEARING OR
HEARINGS. A TO DO THE VOTES TO
ACTUALLY MAKES THE DECISIONS
THAT IS OUR PROCESS AND- THEN
WE ARE GETTING CLOSE TO THE MAY
REVISE SO BEFORE I MOVED TO THE
FIRST PANEL. CENTER A JOB OVER
SENATOR MEN TO HAVE ANY OPENING.
COMMENTS FIVE YES SENATOR MAY.
YEAH I'VE I'VE- THINK WHEN WE
LAST GAMES WE YOU HAVE TO YOUR
MIKE. THERE YOU GO. THEY TURNED
IT OFF AND THEN YOU TURN THE.
THEY HAVE. I THINK WHEN WE LAST
CONVENE WE WERE DEALING WITH
THE OF IN PERSON- AND I JUST
WANT TO AMPLE. THAT FITS TO ME
WE DON'T TAKE HUGE STEP
BACKWARDS IN THE GOVERNOR PANDA
THAT CREDIT THAT ARE SO. ARE IN
PERSON JUST ONCE. TO EVERYONE
WHO WANTS IT. HOWEVER ELEAZAR
ALSO. NEED TO BE ABLE TO. THE
OPTION OF IN DISTANCE. TO
ANYONE WHO IT BECAUSE- THE
REALITY IS ARE MANY PARENTS
THAT IF TO ME THAT ARE ON. WITH
IN PERSONS AND GIVEN THE NEEDS.
OF OUR TIME I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT WE OFFER THAT
OPTIONS. PARENTS ALSO BROUGHT
IT TO ME CONCERNS ABOUT
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES THE
NUMBER OF- MINUTES THAT
TEACHERS ACTUALLY PROVIDED FOR
CONSTRUCTION PER DAY. I'VE
HEARD REPORTS THAT SOME ELEAZAR
OFFERED AS FEW AS A HUNDRED
TWENTY MINUTES OF INSTRUCTION
PER DAY- SO WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THAT IN THE COMING FALL AS
WELL. I'M SO GRATEFUL THAT WE
HAVE A CONGRESS AND PRESIDENT
THAT ARE WILLING TO PARTNER
WITH THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORT. THE RESUMPTION IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION. WITH A-
BOUNTY OF- THE- IN FINDING AND-
I HOPE THAT WILL USE THOSE
FUNDS TO HELP ADDRESS NOT ONLY
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION MENTAL
HEALTH WHICH ARE GONNA BE SO
CRITICAL- BUT ALSO JUST MAKING
SURE. THAT WE ADDRESS THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES WE FACE
THAT WE OFFER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION EVERYONE WHO WANTS
IT- BUT THEY WE MAINTAIN SOME
FLEXIBILITY- GIVEN THAT SOME
PARENTS ARE FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS MAY BE UNCOMFORTABLE
WITH GOING BACK TO SCHOOL.
THANK YOU CARE. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND SINCE YOU RAISED
THE SUBJECT. OF WE WILL BE AT
SOME POINT CONSIDERING THE
TOPIC THAT YOU JUST RAISED ITS
NOT AT THIS HEARING. BOB LET ME
JUST SUBSCRIBED TO YOUR
COMMENTS AND I THINK THAT. THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SAY THAT WE
WANT TO OFFER IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION WANT MAKE SURE.
THEY'RE I THINK ONE OF THE- THE
CONTROLLING FACTORS. IS THAT.
ONCE WE COME OUT THE BAND. IT
IS LIKE THAT WE WILL REACH TO.
L. A. ON ENROLLMENT. AND WE
DON'T WANT TO DO ANY. THAT FOR
CHALLENGE AD NOT OFF FLOOD.
FOR THE PARA THAT NOT. TO HAVE
THEIR TO COME BACK IN PERSON
RIGHT AWAY. IS AN ENROLLMENT
ISSUE AS MUCH AS ANYTHING ELSE
AND- THE OTHER THING IS WE'RE
HEARING LOUDLY AND CLEARLY. I
THINK FROM THE PARENTS THAT
REALLY WANT IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION AND DON'T WANT ANY
OPTION. AND I THINK WE ARE
REALLY SYMPATHETIC WE WANT TO
MAKE IN PERSON OPTION. THE
DEFAULT BUT- YOUR NEW WANTS IS
A VERY IMPORTANT ONE TO KNOW
AND I THINK WE WILL BE
CONSIDERING THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. FOLLOW WITH THAT- AND
SENT OR BOGUS THIS ONE OF THREE
OF AND SHE IS FREE SO I THE
HOME SO. WITH THE WE MOVE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS SCHOOL IN
THE PRIORITY AND POP. I'M I
THINK THIS IS THE A MAJOR ITEM
OF THE FOR THAT IS SO THE CHEN
TODAY AND WE HAVE WITH US SIX
OUR WITNESSES- FOUR PANELISTS
SIR CORTEZ FROM OHIO OFF. AND
WE GUARD FROM THE OF EDUCATION
KIM FRIENDS L. FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION DEBORAH
ORTIZ CLASSIFIED FOOD SERVICE
FOOD SERVICE EMPLOYEE FROM THE
ROSEVILLE CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT.
JENNIFER LEMAIRE AT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OFSTUDENT
NUTRITION SERVICES FOR SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED IN AND TO
CHANGE THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF FOOD
BANKS AND I AM AWARE. THAT IS
SORTIES ACTUALLY A JOB AS
OPPOSED TO THE REST OF US AND
HAS TO BE DONE AND BACK TO OUR
JOB BY TEN O'CLOCK SO FOR
RUNNING LIKE IN ANY WAY I AM
GOING TO MOVE HER UP TO MAKE
SURE THAT SHE IS TAKEN CARE OF.
SO WITH THAT I WILL RECOGNIZE
PEOPLE FOR OPENING COMMENTS IN
THE ORDER THAT I NAMED THEM AND
SO THAT. BEGINS WITH SARAH
CORTEZ WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE.
GOOD MORNING SIR TENS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
WAS ASKED TODAY TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE STATE
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAM
DISCUSSED SOME OF THE MORE
RECENT FEDERAL AND STATE
CHANGES TO THE SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS YOU TO PANDEMIC.
UNDESCRIBED THE SENATE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS PROPOSAL. THE
SCHOOLS SHOULD ALSO BIPARTISAN
IN THIS OR FEDERAL OR STATE
INTEREST PROGRAM. THERE SO- MIL
PROGRESS AS A IN YOUR- BUT
GENERALLY HAVE TO CERTAIN
NUTRITION. AND THE STAY IN
FRONT GOVERNMENT REIMBURSED
DISTRICTS FOR THE MILL THEY
SERVE TO STUDENTS. FOR EXAMPLE
IN TWENTY. THE THAT PURCHASE IN
THE NOW SCHOOL IN PROGRAM
GENERALLY. THREE DOLLARS SIXTY
PER LUNCH AND THREE DOLLARS IN
THIRTEEN PER LIKE. THE STATE
PROGRAM PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
TWENTY FOUR CENTS PER FOR OR-
PRICE FOR THE. BUT GREEN REDUCE
PRICE MAY- GENERALLY STUDENTS
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE IF FAMILY CAN
INCOME- IS OUR HIGH AND 30% THE
FIVE FEDERAL LEVEL WHICH IS
ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT DOLLARS FOR
OF TWO AND THE REDUCE PRICING
JIM IS HUNDRED FIVE PER OF THE
COST LEVEL WHICH ABOUT. FORTY
THOUSAND FOR THREE. I'M
INTERESTED PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS. SOME OF THESE
PROGRAM CHANGES ARE INTENDED TO
ENSURE THAT INTERNSHIP PROGRAMS
CAN IT HERE TO OUR CORPORATE
SAFETY MATTERS WORK TO SUPPORT
ACCESS TO MILLS DURING SCHOOL
CLOSURES. FOR EXAMPLE YOU STA
ALLOWS MILLS TO BE SERVED IN
NAM CONGREGATE SETTINGS AND
PICKED UP. BY THE PARENT OF
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN PRIOR TO THE
PANDEMIC. MILLS ARE REQUIRED TO
BE CERTAIN CONGREGATE SETTINGS
HAYMAN'S. GIN BY PARTICIPANTS
ON SITE. WHEN WE WERE IN LIKE
TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WE SEE ACTION.
BY YOU WOULD STILL TO ALLOW
SCHOOL TO OFFER A SEAMLESS
SUMMER OFF DURING. THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
YEAR AND MAKING THIS OPTION
AVAILABLE TO ALL SCHOOL STUDENT
ORTIZ THIS OPTION IS TYPICALLY
ONLY AVAILABLE DURING SCHOOL
VACATION PERIODS SUCH AS DURING
SUMMER. AND TOO LOW INCOME
AREAS. THIS OPTION MUCH PROGRAM
FLEXIBILITY. TO THE TYPICAL
PROGRAM RULES. FOR EXAMPLE
OFFERING THE SEAMLESS SUMMER
OPTION ELIMINATES THE NEED FOR
SCHOOLS TO DETERMINE
ELIGIBILITY. AND COLLECTING.
TOOLS HOWEVER MOST OFTEN JOB
OFFERING THIS PROGRAM. THE
GOVERNMENT AND ALSO PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL FISCAL SUPPORT TO
SUPPORT SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS WITH THE MAKES THE
PROPOSITION NINETY AND FEDERAL
FUNDS THE STATE PROVIDED A
HUNDRED NINETY TWO MILLION TO
PROVIDE UP TO AN ADDITIONAL
SEVENTY FIVE CENTS PER MEAL
SERVER BETWEEN. MARCH AND
AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ALSO
PROVIDED FUNDING TO HELP
ADDRESS MIDDLE- WATCHING A
REIMBURSEMENT. FROM MARCH TO
JUNE TWENTY TWENTY. AFTER THEY
BRIEFLY JUST. THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS CAUCUS. I'M PAGE SIX
OF YOUR TO AS PROPOSAL. THE
DEMOCRATS PROPOSE MAKING
PROGRESS IN A NUMBER OF
PRIORITY AREAS AND THESE
INCLUDE PROVIDING UNIVERSAL
MALES WHICH FOR FACILITIES TO
ALL STUDENTS. CONTINUING TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL EMAIL
REIMBURSEMENTS AND BUILD OFF
THE LEAPERS CREEK IN AUTHORIZED.
BY THE USDA. BRITISH TELECOM
DURING SCHOOL BREAKS IN SUMMER
BREAKS REDUCE OR ELIMINATE
SCHOOL MIL- MILTON LEDS
INCREASINGLY ATTRITIONAL
CONTENT MILLS AN INCREASE
LOCALLY GROWN FOODS
INSTALLATIONS. AND TO STABILIZE
A SUPPORTER AND SUPPORT THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF TO PROVIDE
FOOD SERVICE AT SCHOOLS THIS
COULD INCLUDE MY REMARKS IN ANY
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS WILL MOVE TO PHILLY.
GARDNER FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. GOOD MORNING. THE
MORNING ELLIE GARNER ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION TONY
THURMOND THE S. S. P. I. AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION PROBABLY SUPPORT YEAR
ROUND ACCESS TO HEALTHY AND
NUTRITIOUS MEALS. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT EDUCATION
ADMINISTERS THREE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY FOUR
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES. AND
LOCAL AGENCY PROGRAM PROVIDERS
THAT OPERATE SEVEN USDA FEDERAL
CHILD NUTRITION MEAL PROGRAMS
THE MEAL PROGRAMS ARE DESIGNED
TO COLLECT PER YOUR ROUND ACTS
TO HEALTH MEALS BY. DURING AND
SCHOOL WHEN SCHOOL'S NOT IN
SESSION AND FOR YOUNG CHILDREN
AND ADULTS IN DAY CARE
PROVIDING MORE THAN ONE BILLION
MEALS AND SNACKS TO ARE MOST AT
RISK AND SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED
CHILDREN. EXISTING FEDERAL
UNIVERSAL MEAL OPTIONS SUCH AS
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY AND
PROVISION TO HELP BREAK DOWN
YOUR PARTICIPATION BARRIERS. A
pALLOWS SCHOOLS IN HIGH NEED
COMMUNITIES WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT PERCENTAGE AT 40% OR
MORE TO OFFER TWO MEALS EACH
SCHOOL DAY. FREE OF CHARGE TO
ALL STUDENTS BASED ON THE
SCHOOLS I S. P. FORMULA THE
SCHOOLS RECEIVE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEALS SERVED
AT EITHER THE FREE OR PAID
RATES. FEDERAL REGULATIONS
REQUIRE THAT DIFFERENCES IN
MALE ME IN MEAL REIMBURSEMENT
AND THE COST OF PROVIDING ALL
MEALS FOR FREE THE MADE UP WITH
NON FEDERAL SIGNS. NO MEAL
APPLICATIONS ARE REQUIRED.
PROVISION TO ALLOW SCHOOLS TO
SERVE MEALS AT NO CHARGE BUT
SIMPLIFIES ME ACCOUNTING AND
CLEANING PROCEDURES BY ALLOWING
THE SCHOOL TO RECEIVE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENTS BASED ON
CLEANING PERCENTAGES THAT IS
ESTABLISHED EVERY FOUR YEARS.
HE SAID HE'S CONFIRMED THAT
THERE IS AN INCREASED
PARTICIPATION IN THE SCHOOL
MEAL PROGRAM. FOR ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUS WHEN ALL KIDS
EAT FOR FREE. WELL NURSING
STUDENTS ARE BETTER ABLE TO
REACH THEIR FULL ACADEMIC
POTENTIAL AND HAVE GREATER
HEALTH OUTCOMES THROUGHOUT
THEIR LIFE. SO LET'S TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE FEDERAL
NUTRITION MEAL WAIVERS. AS OUR
NATION AND STATE BEGIN TO
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC THAT
COULD BE NINETEEN CHILD
NUTRITION MEAL WAIVERS
AUTHORIZED AUST AUTHORIZED BY
THE USDA WILL HELP ENSURE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN CONTINUE TO
HAVE EASY ACCESS THIS SUMMER
ANDFOR THE ENTIRE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEAR HEALTHY
MEALS AND- SNACKS. OFFERED BY
THE SCHOOLS PARTICIPATING IN
THE FEDERAL NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
THIS MEANS THAT THERE IS NO
AREA ELIGIBILITY LIMITATION NO
NEED TO COLLECT MEAL
APPLICATIONS ALL MEALS ARE
SERVED AT A FREE RATE SO THERE
IS NO MEAL DEBT INCURRED BY THE
L. EA. AND THIS CAN THIS IS
ALLOWS FOR CONTINUATION OF NON
CONGREGATE SERVICES SUCH AS
GRAB AND GO AND CURBSIDE PICKUP
MEALS. UNDER THE FEDERAL
WAIVERS FOR THE UPCOMING SCHOOL
YEAR SCHOOLS THAT ARE THAT ARE
APPROVED TO OPERATE THAT
SEAMLESS SUMMER OPTION THAT
SERRA. REFERRED TO YOU CAN
SERVE ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS
OF INCOME LOCATION LEARNING
MODALITY OR SITE TYPE. USDA IS
ALSO PROVIDING A HIGHER MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR MEALS
SERVED THREE THAT SSL. THESE
WAIVERS BRING OUR STATE CLOSER
TO OUR VISION OF UNIVERSAL
MEALS FOR ALL STUDENTS
REGARDLESS OF INCOME OR IS IT
OUT. WHAT'S ABOUT THAT
UNIVERSAL MEALS ONCE THE
FEDERAL WAIVERS EXPIRES. AS WE
DISCUSSED A MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTION FOR UNIVERSAL MEALS IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS IMPORTANT THAT
ARE UNIVERSAL MEALS PROGRAM BE
FISCALLY SUSTAINABLE AND THAT
WE MAXIMIZE ALL FEDERAL MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
BEFORE SUPPLEMENTING WITH
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDS. THE
CITY HAS THREE RECOMMENDATIONS
TO GUIDE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE FIRST
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT WE
REQUIRE ALL SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL
SCHOOL NUTRITION MEAL PROGRAM
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE THE STATE
UNIVERSAL MEAL REIMBURSEMENT
SUPPLEMENTS. WITHOUT FULL FULL
PARTICIPATION CALIFORNIA'S
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS WOULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED AND THAT
REDUCTION WOULD NEED TO BE BACK
FILLED BY STATE GENERAL FUNDS.
PERSPECTIVE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN THE CALIFORNIA FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS WAS TWO
POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS. WE
NEED TO MAXIMIZE THE ONGOING
FEDERAL FUNDING AND DESIGN THE
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL MEAL
PROGRAM TO SUPPLEMENT NOT
SUPPLANT THE FEDERAL MEAL
PROGRAMS. BY THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR ALL STUDENTS TO RECEIVE UP
TO TWO FREE MEALS EACH DAY
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME
ELIGIBILITY THE CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL MEAL PROGRAM WE NEED
TO PROVIDE ONGOING STATE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEALS SERVED
TO CHILDREN WHO DO NOT MEET THE
FEDERAL INCOME OR ELIGIBILITY
STATUS FOR FREE OR REDUCED
MEALS. FROM THE HEALTH CLAIMS
AT THE FEDERAL FREE RATE NO
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDS WILL BE
NEEDED AS IT'S PAID A 100% I
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT. MEALS
CLEANED AT THE FEDERAL REDUCED
PRICE RATE IN PAID RATES WOULD
BE NEED TO BE SUPPLEMENTED BY
STATE FUNDS SO THE ALLEY A CAN
PROVIDE. MEALS FREE TO ALL
STUDENTS EVEN WHEN STUDENTS MAY
NOT QUALIFY FOR FREE. WE
REALIZE THAT NOT ALL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA CHOOSE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH FOR SCHOOL
BREAKFAST PROGRAM. ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO CHARTERS DO NOT
PARTICIPATE CURRENTLY. MANY
TIMES THIS IS BECAUSE THE
SCHOOL IS LOCATED IN
COMMUNITIES WITH A VERY LOW
POPULATION OF FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEAL ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
THE CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL MEALS
PROGRAM MAY HELP TO INCENTIVIZE
ALL SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAMS.
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT ON THE
FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAMS ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE THE FEDERAL
MEAL MEAL REIMBURSEMENT. BUT
THEY MUST STILL PROVIDE ONE
NUTRITIONALLY ADEQUATE MEAL TO
ALL NEEDY STUDENTS. WITH THE
STATE'S MEAL REIMBURSEMENT IS
ONLY TWENTY FOUR CENTS PER MEAL
WELL THE FEDERAL MERE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT AT. AT THE FREE
RATE FOR LUNCH IS UP TO THREE
DOLLARS AND SIXTY CENTS PER
LUNCH SERVICE. OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDED. IS TO SUPPORT
ACCESS TO HEALTHIER MEALS WHEN
SCHOOL IS NOT IN SESSION IN
THREE SPECIFIC WAYS. ONE
OFFERING ADDITIONAL STATE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT FOR AT LEAST
OPERATE THE SEAMLESS SUMMER
OPTION DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS
IS A HEALTHY MEAL STANDARD
ADMINISTRATIVE AT THE END IS
ADMINISTRATIVELY LESS
BURDENSOME FOR SCHOOLS. THE
SECOND WAY IS A LEADING
FINANCIAL LOSSES TO SCHOOL
SUMMER FOOD SERVICE OPERATIONS
THE CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL MEAL
PROGRAM COULD SUPPLEMENT THE
FEDERAL SEAMLESS SUMMER OPTION
MEAL REIMBURSEMENT RATE TO
MATCH THE HIGHER SUMMER FOOD
SERVICE PROGRAM FEDERAL RATES.
AND THIRD ENSURING THAT THE
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL MEAL
PROGRAM DESIGN DOES NOT HAVE
UNINTENDED QUESTION AT AN
INTENDED CONSEQUENCES IN
ELIMINATING SUMMER FOOD SERVICE
WORKER JOBS. IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO MENTION THE
POTENTIAL AND ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE WORKERS
WHO ARE TYPICALLY THE LOWEST
EARNING POSITIONS IN A SCHOOL.
IN MANY CASES THESE POSITIONS
ARE FILLED BY WOMEN OF COLOR
AND THEY ARE NOT FULL TIME GOOD
SERVICE WORKERS DEPEND ON
WORKING THE SUMMER MONTHS AND
SOMETIMES YEAR ROUND. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE
NOT CREATING A PROGRAM THAT
WOULD RESULT IN FOOD SERVICE
STAFF LAYOFFS IN THE SUMMER
MONTHS BECAUSE OF A LOWER
PARTICIPATION ELECTRONIC
BENEFIT CARDS ARE USED IN LIEU
OF SERVING MEALS. OUR THIRD AND
FINAL RECOMMENDATION IS TO
INCENTIVIZE YEAR ROUND ACCESS
TO MEALS BY INCREASING FUNDING
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANT GRANTS.
ASSISTANCE GRANTS TO ELEAZAR.
THIS CAN BUILD THEIR MEAL
PROGRAMS AND IN HALF HE ENHANCE
ACCESS TO FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAMS
WHEN SCHOOL IS NOT IN SESSION
AND PROVIDES GREATER OFFERINGS
OF CALIFORNIA BROWN SUITS.
WHILE THE STATE WHILE ONGOING
STATE FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL PROGRAM IS
A SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT. WE
NEED TO INVEST IN OUR CHILDREN
THEIR HEALTH AND THEIR ACADEMIC
SUCCESS. OF COURSE THERE LONG
TERM POTENTIAL TO THRIVE. ONE
SEED CANNOT PROVIDE A
DEFINITIVE COST BREAKDOWN FOR A
CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL MEAL
PROGRAM AT THIS TIME. OUR
PRELIMINARY PROJECTED ESTIMATE
IS ABOUT ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AS AN ONGOING
INVESTMENT IN LOCAL ASSISTANCE
AND APPROXIMATELY FOUR MILLION
IN CD COSTS. IT'S CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS AND I HAVE WITH ME
TODAY CAN FRENZAL WHOSE CD IS
DIRECTOR OF NUTRITION SERVICES.
WE ARE HAPPY TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTIONS AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. AND SO CAN FRIENDS
THOSE JUST AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS SHE'S NOT GOING TO BE
PERCENT DECLINE YES SIR GREAT
JUST CHECKING. THEN MS ORTIZ
ARE WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE-
YOUR UP. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU THIS MORNING MY
NAME IS DEBORAH ORTIZ AND I'M A
FOOD SERVICES DELIVERY DRIVER
FOR THE RESPONSE CITY
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT I'VE
WORKED FOR THE CHURCH SERVICES
DEPARTMENT FOR THIRTEEN YEARS
AND I'M CSTA MEMBER. I WOULD
LIKE TO SHARE MY PERSPECTIVE AS
AN ESSENTIAL WORKER WHO'S BEEN
WORKING ONSITE THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE PANDEMIC IN ANSWERING
THE THREE PROVIDED QUESTIONS
QUESTION NUMBER ONE WHAT WAS
THE EXPERIENCE AND FOOD SERVICE
EMPLOYEES DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND WHAT CHALLENGES ARE FACED
IN MEETING THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS IN THE COMING SCHOOL
YEAR. THE WAS US FOR. AND
REWARD WHEN ALL THE OTHER
DEPARTMENTS IN THE DISTRICT
WERE SHUT DOWN I'M WORKING FROM
HOME. WE WERE AT WORK FEEDING
OUR STUDENTS AND COMMUNITIES.
WE CONTINUE TO WORK EVERY DAY
SPRING BREAK INCLUDING BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T STILL NEEDED SEATS.
WILL MANY OTHER PRIVATE SECTOR
FOOD SERVICE WITH A WORKERS
RECEIVING HAZARDS HEY WE DID
NOT. WE HAD TO WORK DOING WHAT
WAS NEEDED TO BE DONE THE SAME
WAGES. IT WAS THE LOWEST PAID
WORKERS IN THE DISTRICTS THAT
CONTINUE TO DO OUR JOBS. OUR
NEW NORM BECAME OUT SUNGLASSES
AND WORKING OUTSIDE IN THE HEAT
OR COLD. WITHOUT PROPER
EQUIPMENT TO COOL OURSELVES FOR
THE FED. BEING SHORT STAFFED
BECAME A DAILY OCCURRENCE ONLY
EMPLOYEES FROM ONE SIDE TO
COVER ANOTHER IS DONE
REGULARLY. JOBS ARE POSTED
REPEATEDLY WITH NO APPLICANTS.
PART TIME LOW PAYING AND AT A
HIGHER RISK OF EXPOSURE. THESE
POSITIONS CONTINUE TO GO ON
STAFF AND WILL BE A BIG FACTOR
IN THE COMING SCHOOL YEAR. FOR
THIS REASON IT IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE EXTEND THE
LAST MARCH OR IN OUR FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS WORKING IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. IT IS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE OUR LOWEST
WAGE EARNERS. WITH ADDITIONAL
PAY AND MORE HOURS. MANY FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS ARE EARNING THE
MINIMUM WAGE OR SLIGHTLY MORE
THESE ARE THE SAME WORKERS WHO
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES OF. AND
I'M- HAVING TO CONTINUALLY
ADAPT TO CONSTANT CHANGES HAS
BEEN TOUGH AND COMMUNICATION IS
AN ISSUE. THE DISTRICT IS IN
THE PROCESS OF FIGURING OUT HOW
WILL BE SERVING LUNCHES IN THE
COMING SCHOOL YEAR. WE HAVE
BEEN SERVING GRAB AND GO STYLE
COLD. BUT THE DISTRICT WOULD
LIKE TO RETURN TO A MORE
TRADITIONAL HOT LUNCH ON A
TRAY. IF WE RETURN TO HOT
LUNCHES NOT BEING FULLY STAFFED
THIS WILL BE A BIG CHALLENGE.
YES THROUGHOUT ALL OF THE
GRATITUDE THAT FAMILIES HAVE
EXPRESSED ASK ME THIS WILL
TRULY APPRECIATE. QUESTION
NUMBER TWO HOW DO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS STOP SUMMER MEAL
PROGRAMS MY DISTRICT THE SENATE
INTEREST FORM. AND THEN SELECT
PEOPLE TO WORK BASED ON
DISTRICT NEEDS AND WHETHER OR
NOT YOU HAVE A SERVICE STATE
CERTIFICATE. MOST FOOD SERVICE
STAFF OR TEN MONTH. EMPLOYEES
IF YOU WORK THIS SUMMER MY
SINCE YOU WILL NOT THE SAME. AS
A TWELVE MONTH EMPLOYEE WHAT.
FOR HE WOULD NOT BE A- SICK. AS
A TEN MONTH EMPLOYEE WOULD
ACCRUE TENTS DAYS. AS A TWELVE
MONTH TO BUT APPROVED TO. SO
EVEN THOUGH YOU WERE ALL MONTHS
BUT LET OUT THE ADDITION. TWO
SIX. QUESTION NUMBER THREE WHAT
IS NEEDED TO HELP SERVICE. TO
DO THEIR JOB SAFELY. TRAINING A
QUICK AND P. TRAINING IS
ESSENTIAL DO ANY JOB THEY-
TEACHERS REGULAR GET
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT DAYS.
WHAT PROVIDE CLASSES EMPLOYEE
WITH HER. DEVELOPMENT FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS ARE REQUIRED TO
HAVE CONTINUING EDUCATION
HOURS. THEY ARE ALSO REQUIRED
TO HAVE A SERVE SAVE
CERTIFICATE EITHER A MANAGER
CERTIFICATE OR- CERTIFICATE. MY
DISTRICT PROVIDES A BOOK FOR
STUDYING AND OCCASIONALLY A
COUPLE HOURS AGO RUBIO. MANY
PEOPLE DO NOT PASS THE TEST THE
FIRST TIME TO TAKE IT AND MUST
TAKE IT SEVERAL TIMES. HAVING
COMPREHENSIVE TRAINING AND
PRACTICE TESTS WOULD BE ERY
HELPFUL AND DECREASE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE HAVING TO RETAKE THE
TEST. EQUIPMENT NEEDS HAVE
CHANGED SINCE THE WAY WE ARE
PACKAGING FOOD AND SERVING HAS
CHANGED. HAVING THE PROPER
TOOLS TO DO THE JOB INSTEAD OF
MAKING DO WITH WHAT WE HAVE.
WOULD MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
SAFETY. SIMPLE THINGS LIKE
PROVIDING FOOD SERVICE WORKERS
WITH CARTS TO MOVE BOXES OF
SHOES ARE PROVIDED TO TENTS
THAT HANDLES. INSTEAD OF
AWKWARD CARDBOARD BOXES WOULD
HELP INCREASE SAFETY. OUR FOOD
SERVICE WAREHOUSE DOESN'T HAVE
A LARGE AND A WALK IN
REFRIGERATOR OR FREEZER. TO
ACCOMMODATE THE AMOUNT. WE ARE
NOW BRINGING IN WEEK WHAT. THE
VOLUME OF FOOD HAS INCREASED
TREMENDOUSLY SINCE THE MAY ALSO
ANNOUNCE WE ALL STUDENTS AND WE
ARE PACKAGING THE MEALS. MANY
SCHOOLS DID NOT OFFER BREAKFAST
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WHICH WE
ARE NOW PROVIDING. THIS IS
INCREASE THE PHYSICAL ASPECT OF
THE JOB AND MAKE THINGS LIKE
PROPER LIFTING MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER TO AVOID INJURIES.
WITH THE PROSPECT OF KIDS
RETURNING TO THE LUNCH ROOMS
PLEXIGLAS BARRIERS WILL NEED TO
BE INSTALLED IN THE SERVING
AREAS TO KEEP STAFF PROTECT IT.
AND OF COURSE THE NEED. FOR PP
CONTINUES PLEASE KEEP THE MASS
AND CLASS COMING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS IF YOU
HAVE. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- JUST BEFORE WE MOVED TO
JENNIFER LOVE THERE LET ME SAY
THAT. BECAUSE OF MS ORTIZ HAS A
TIME CONSTRAINT IF ANYBODY HAS.
QUESTIONS FOR HER WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE THOSE TO THE TOP THE
MINUTE WE GET DONE WITH THE
NEXT TO. SO EVEN- MICHAEL. HAVE
QUEST FOR ME OR TWO. I HAVE THE
READY FOR THE TIME. SO WE'LL
MOVE TO J. LEBEAU THE X. TO. OF
STOOD ATTRITION SERVICES AT ST
FRANCISCO UNIFIED. TO THE
COMMITTEE. THE MORNING JENNIFER
HARDS ARE KIND OF DIRECTOR AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH DEBORAH FOR EVERYTHING
THAT YOU HAVE DONE. THROUGHOUT
THIS PANDEMIC AND I'M GETTING A
LITTLE- THE COUNTRY NOW FOR-
THE WORDS EITHER STASH IT'S
BEEN MY HONOR TO WORK IN SCHOOL
NUTRITION FOR TWENTY YEARS. AND
ONE OF THE REASON IT'S BEEN
HONOR IS BECAUSE I GET TO WORK
WITH PEOPLE LIKE YOU. WHO HAVE
DONE THE WORK IN THIS WORK AND
TO CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK
BECAUSE YOU PRIORITIZE THE
CHILDREN THAT WE SERVE. AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THIS IS
NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH YOU'RE A
WEEK AND WE SHOULD BE
CELEBRATING YOU EVERY SINGLE
WEEK AND THIS IS A SPECIAL WAY
TO CELEBRATE PEOPLE LIKE
YOURSELF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE- I'M
HERE. TO TALK TO YOU ALL. THE
IMPACT UNIVERSAL MEALS CAN HAVE
ON CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN IN
FAMILIES AND WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE MAKE THIS CRITICAL
MOVED. TO BE THE FIRST IN THE
NATION. TO MAKE SCHOOL MEALS
FREE FOR ALL CHILDREN. MARCH
THIRTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED MADE THE
DECISION TO CLOSE SCHOOLS. IN
RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE DIDN'T
THINK HE WAS ONLY GOING TO BE
THREE WEEKS UNTIL WE RE OPENED
OUR SCHOOLS AGAIN. WE CREATED.
GRABBING GOES AND MULTIPLE
COVERED RESPONSE MEALS AND
AFTER FOURTEEN MONTHS AND LINES
OF PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS
WRAPPING AROUND CITY BLOCKS AND
NEARLY SEVEN MILLION MEALS
LATER. WE HAVE SEEN THAT EVEN
IN THE CITY OF WEALTH LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO SAN FRANCISCO FREE
MEALS ARE NEEDED. THE LINES OF
ADULTS REPRESENT A LINES OF
CHILDREN WE NORMALLY SEE IN
CAFETERIAS PATIENTLY WAITING
FOR THE ONLY THING THAT ISN'T
FREE AND OUR FREE EDUCATION
SYSTEM. ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS
YOU NEED IN ORDER TO BE
PREPARED TO LEARN MEALS. FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS I HAVE SEEN
THE IMPACTS OF THIS INEQUITY
HAS HAD ON CHILDREN THEIR
FAMILIES AND THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
WELL MALES ARE STIGMATIZED IN
EVERY SCHOOL WHERE THEY ARE NOT
FREE FOR ALL AND AS A RESULT
CHILDREN WILL CHOOSE NOT TO
EAT. TO AVOID BEING SEEN AS A
POOR KID. EARNS WILL REFUSE TO
COMPLETE THE MAIL APPLICATION
SO THAT THEY ARE NOT SEEN AS A
POOR FAMILY. BECAUSE OF THIS IT
WILL STRETCH THEIR ALREADY
TIGHT BUDGETS TO SEND LUNCHES
FOR THEIR CHILDREN. NINE TIMES
WHEN BOTH THE MONEY AND THE
FOOD STAMPS RUN OUT OR MOM IS
STILL BUSY SHE FORGETS WHICH
JUST HAPPENED TO ME. THIS YOU
KNOW WILL COME THROUGH WHERE
ONE FINDS AND WE WILL PROVIDE
THE MEAL. AND BECAUSE SAN
FRANCISCO LIKE MANY DISTRICTS
DID BEFORE LEGISLATION MANDATED
IT WILL PROVIDE THAT MAIL AND
NOT WORRY ABOUT COLLECTING
THERE'S NO FEES. THE DISTRICT
GENERAL FUND WILL TAKE ON THAT
DEBT IMPACTING THE FUNDING FOR
CLASSROOMS. THE OTHER SCENARIO
THAT HAPPENS IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND MANY OTHER DISTRICTS IN
CALIFORNIA AS HAS BEEN ATTESTED
TO BY THE WITNESSES BEFORE ME.
FAMILY SIMPLY DO NOT QUALIFY
FOR THE FREE AND REDUCED PRICE
MEALS. DID YOU KNOW THAT A
FAMILY OF FOUR CAN MAKE NO MORE
THAN FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED TO QUALIFY FOR FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE MEALS. THE
FEDERAL INCOME GUIDELINES
SIMPLY DO NOT TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE COST OF
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA WHERE EVEN
THE DIFFERENCES WITHIN OUR OWN
STATE. THE AVERAGE RANGE IN SAN
FRANCISCO FOR SEVEN HUNDRED AND
THIRTY NINE SQUARE FOOT
APARTMENT IS TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED DOLLARS. WELL IN MY
HOMETOWN OF BAKERSFIELD ELEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS WILL DO THE JOB.
SO WE REPEAT THE SAME CYCLE
WHERE FAMILIES BUDGET IS
STRETCHED. THEY MAKE GOOD
CHOICES THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
MAKE A LUNCH DINNER CRUISE. YOU
MAY ASK WHAT ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY PROVISION
OR C. ISN'T THAT A SOLUTION. I
GREW RESPOND THAT MANY
DISTRICTS IN CAMBY BUT FOR MANY
IT IS NOT IN MY FORMER DISTRICT
I WAS ABLE TO PUT SEVENTY ONE
OUT OF EIGHTY SIX SCHOOLS ON
THAT PROGRAM. WOW MY DEPARTMENT
WAS PROVIDING FREE MEALS FOR
ALL CHILDREN AT THE SEVENTY ONE
SCHOOLS WE WERE NOT RECEIVING
FREE REIMBURSEMENT FOR ALL OF
THOSE MEALS AND FOR THE
CHILDREN AT THE FIFTEEN SCHOOLS
WITHOUT PHOEBE THE BILL PROGRAM
WAS STILL STIGMATIZED. IN SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAD OVER FIFTY
SCHOOLS ON CD BUT WHEN WE HAD
TO RENEW FOR THE PROGRAM AT THE
END OF THE FOUR YEARS. WE WENT
TO IS ONLY TWENTY BECAUSE
THIRTY SITES NO LONGER QUALIFY
DUE TO THE SHIFTING INCOMES AND
THE PRIOR FEDERAL MINISTRATIONS
USE OF PUBLIC CHARGE. FAMILIES
WHO NEEDED CALFRESH IN CAL
WORKS STOPPED PLYING FOR AND
RECEIVING THOSE BENEFITS.
BECAUSE THE BASIS FOR THE
SEAVIEW QUALIFICATIONS WORK HOW
WORKS IN CALFRESH. EVEN WITH
THE PROPOSED CHANGES TO C. P.
IN AMERICA'S FAMILY PLAN IT IS
ESTIMATED THAT 43% OF
CALIFORNIA. SCHOOLS WITH STILL
NOT QUALIFY. C. HAS BEEN THE
FOR GOVERNMENT STEP TOWARD.
MEALS BUT WE CAN DO MORE AND WE
NEED TO DO MORE. TO PROVIDED BY
FEEDING AMERICA SHOW THAT IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN ARE MORE LIKELY TO BE
STUDENTS EACH YEAR AND THAT
ELEVEN POINT TWO MILLION
CHILDREN. ONE IN SEVEN LIVED IN
FOOD INSECURE HOMES.
DEMONSTRATED THE FAMILIES LIVE
ON A WIRES EDGE WE'VE ALL HEARD
THE ADAGE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK. BUT THE PANDEMIC
REVEAL THE CIRCUMSTANCES ARE
FAR MORE DIRE. WE NEED TO LEARN
FROM THIS CAN DAMAGE AND DO
MORE TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS
COULD BE A RELIABLE SOURCE OF
FREE MEALS FOR ALL HOUSEHOLDS.
THE WEST SIDE OF SAN FRANCISCO
TYPICALLY WEALTHY ECONOMICALLY
SEARCH YOUR HOMES. SO THE
LARGEST EMISSION OF
UNEMPLOYMENT APPLICATIONS AT
ONE POINT DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE ALSO A NEW STORY SHOWING
MILES LONG LINES AT THE BANKS
FAMILIES WHO NEVER THOUGHT THEY
WOULD BE FOOD INSECURE. WHERE
WE WHERE WE ARE COMING OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC'S FAMILIES WILL BE
FEELING THE ECONOMIC EFFECTS
FOR YEARS TO COME. CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALSO FEELING THE ECONOMIC
UNCERTAINTIES OF THE
WILDFLOWERS WILDFIRES RATHER.
AND OTHER ECONOMIC. AND
ENVIRONMENTAL DISASTERS. WE DO
NOT KNOW WHEN AND WHERE THEY
WILL STRIKE BEAT THE IMPACT US
ALL. LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE FREE
EMAILS WITHOUT COMPLETING A
MEAL APPLICATION IN THE MIDDLE
OF A CRISIS. INVESTORS CAN
RECEIVE THE NECESSARY FUNDING
WHEN PROVIDING THESE MEALS.
MANY HAVE ALSO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS THAT THE MOVIE
UNIVERSAL MEALS WILL HAVE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON HOW SCHOOLS
RECEIVE THEIR FUNDING.
SPECIFICALLY OF ALL STUDENTS
RECEIVE FREE EMAILS THE
INCENTIVE TO COMPLETE THE FORMS
NECESSARY TO FIND SCHOOLS WILL
GO AWAY. THE CHALLENGE THIS
NOTION WE DON'T LOOK AT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO A SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENTED ALTERNATIVE INCOME
FORMS FOR THEIR C. P. SITES.
FOR EXAMPLE STEPHANIE BRUCE IN
PALM SPRINGS HAS SCHOOLS
CONTACT FAMILIES ASKING THEM TO
COMPLETE THESE FORMS SO THAT
THEY CAN HAVE PROPER FUNDING
FOR THEIR CHILD'S CLASSROOM. I
KNOW THERE ARE MANY CONGRESO TO
BE HAD. I KNOW THERE ARE MANY
PRIORITIES I KNOW MANY ARE
SAYING SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
GETTING A LOT OF MONEY. LET ME
SAY THIS TO YOU. UNIVERSAL
MEALS NEED TO BE IN EVERY
CONVERSATION. PROVIDING FREE
MEALS AND OUR FREE EDUCATION
SYSTEM NEEDS TO BE A PRIORITY.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
ENSURE EVERY STUDENT HAS THEIR
NEEDS MET. SO THAT THEY CAN BE
PREPARED TO LEARN. AND WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE OUR HEROES AND SHE
ROES ARE TAKING CARE OF IN
THEIR JOBS. THE TIME FOR
UNIVERSAL MEALS IS NOW. AND I'M
HERE TO TAKE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS. ANDREW FROM THE
FOODBANKS EUROPE. THANK YOU
SURELY MEMBERS- WE ALL AGREE NO
CHILD SHOULD GO HUNGRY IN OUR
GREAT STATE YET THE SHAMEFUL
REALITY IS THAT OUR CHILDREN
ARE CONFRONTING HUNGER CRISIS.
ACCORDING TO MOST RECENT DATA
FROM THE SENSORS HOUSEHOLD POLL
SURVEY NEARLY A QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIAN HOUSEHOLDS WITH
CHILDREN ARE FOOD INSECURE WITH
DEEP INJUSTICES FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. 27% OF
FAMILIES IDENTIFYING IS NOT
NEXT 30% OF THOSE IDENTIFYING
AS MULTI RACIAL AN ASTONISHING.
THIRTY FIVE POINT 5% OF BLACK
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN
CORPORATE SECURITY. THE
RESEARCH IS CRYSTAL CLEAR ON
THE SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES OF
CHILDHOOD HUNGER NOT ONLY YOUR
CHILDREN BUT OUR SOCIETY AND A
SIGNAL OF HOW URGENT IT IS TO
ADDRESS AND PREVENT IT. EVEN
ONE INCIDENT OF CHILDHOOD
HUNGER CAN HAVE CONSEQUENCES
LASTING INTO ADULTHOOD. THIS
COMES NOT ONLY FROM THE
PHYSICAL PAIN OF HUNGER BUT THE
TOXIC STRESS OF NOT HAVING
ENOUGH MONEY FOR FOOD. AND NOT
KNOWING WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL
MAY COME FROM. AND FOR CHILDREN
WE KNOW THAT IS ALL TOO REAL
EVEN THE SCHOOL MEALS ARE OFTEN
THE ONLY TO EAT DURING THE DAY
AND A GREAT HARDSHIPS WE'VE
HEARD- BUT BETTER THAN I CAN
DESCRIBE MY PREVIOUS WITNESSES.
THAT KOBE IS PUT ON SCHOOLS AND
FAMILIES I WOULD ALSO LIFT UP
THAT WAS SCHOOL AND HEROES ON
FRIDAY WE CELEBRATE THE AMAZING
WORK OF DEBORAH JENNIFER AND
EVERYONE- TO CONTINUE TO FEED
CHILDREN. TO THIS CRISIS MY
GRATITUDE. AS A POLICY RESPONSE.
WHICH OF COURSE FOCUS ON.
CHILDREN FIRST. AND APPLAUD THE-
OF THE- AND PARTICULARLY THE
SENATE TO DO THAT. BUT HUNGRY
CHILDREN LIVE IN EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WE WILL LEAVE THEM
BEHIND IF WE DO NOT ADOPT
POLICIES TO ACHIEVE FREE SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL CHILDREN. WE
ALREADY HEARD FROM MISSILE ARE
BUT I WOULD JUST HIGHLY- THAT
THE NATIONAL DATA FROM FEEDING
AMERICA SHOW THAT 29% ALMOST A
THIRD OF CHILDREN. WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE LIVE ABOVE THE INCOME
THRESHOLDS WHICH WE ALREADY
HEARD ARE FAR TOO LOW. THAT
DYNAMIC IS WORSENED WITH THE
PRESSURE. OF LOW INCOME WORKING
FAMILIES STATING FACING GREATER
COSTS DURING THE OPEN. LACK OF
PUBLIC TRANSIT. UP YOU KNOW- HE
BEAT OTHER POSSIBLE INCOME
FAMILY SPACE. AS WELL LOW
INCOME FAMILIES- IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES DOING ESSENTIAL
WORK TO POWER OUR ECONOMY TO
FEED THE REST OF US. ARE
ELIGIBLE AND ARE FRIED AFRAID
APPLY. AT ALL. PERSONALLY OF
THESE I AM ARE TO. YOUR
DISTRICT. BUT SECOND HARVEST
STILL CAN BE. SERVING SO MANY
FAMILY JUST ABOUT THE INCOME
THRESHOLD AND SECOND PERSON
SANTA CRUZ. DEALING WITH SUCH
DEEP COMMUNITY FEARS THEY HAD
TO DEVELOP UNDERGROUND FOOD
DISTRIBUTIONS. AND WE KNOW THAT
SAME CHILLING EFFECT IS KEPT SO
MANY FAMILIES WERE ELIGIBLE.
FROM APPLYING FOR PUBLIC GOOD
PROGRAMS LIKE SCHOOL MEALS.
MEANWHILE AS WE ALREADY HEARD
SUCH CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
DISTRICTS MUCH PROGRAMS HAVE
GONE DEEP INTO DEBT DUE TO THE
HIGHER COSTS AND LOWER
REIMBURSEMENTS. THAT MEAL MAYBE
IT HAS BEEN A LIFELINE FOR
CHILDREN BEEN A HARDSHIP FOR
SCHOOLS. THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT
THE BENEFITS OF FREE SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL CHILDREN ARE
LEGION. HOUSE UNIVERSITY CAME
OUT JUST TWO WEEKS AGO SCHOOLS
ARE THAT SINGLE HEALTHIEST
PLACE AMERICANS ARE EATING. THE
RIGHT CENTER HAS FOUND THAT
SCHOOLS CAN LOWER COSTS. BY
MOVING TO UNIVERSAL MALES BUT
PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW HOW MANY
MEALS ARE PURCHASING THE PLAN
FOR THAT AND THE PURCHASE IN
BULK. AND WE JUST HEARD FROM
JENNIFER LOVE ARE BUT THE
ABILITY TO MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
PROVISIONS. SO HE SAID HE SAID
MOST OF ALL THOUGH THAT SCHOOL
MEALS FOR ALL IMPROVE STUDENT
ATTENDANCE BEHAVIOR ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT. IT'S IMPROVED
SCORES IN SPELLING READING AND
MATH DIETARY INTAKE PROTECTING
A CHILD TO THE- OF THE CITY AND
CURRENT GROUP INSURANCE MENTAL
HEALTH. BY REDUCING ANXIETY
DEPRESSION HYPERACTIVITY. I
JUST HAD TO MAKE THE GOOD NEWS
IS THAT WE'VE LEARNED THAT WE
CAN MAKE A DIFFERENCE THANKS TO
THE WAIVERS THAT CD YOU
MENTIONED WE HAVE THE TOOLS TO
WRITE SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL WE
MUST CONTINUE THIS VITAL
POLICY. THE WAY SCHOOL CAMPUSES
ARE CLOSED THOSE OUT OF SCHOOL
TIMES OR THE HUNGRIEST FOR
CHILDREN ACCORDING TO THE FOOD
RESEARCH AND ACTION CENTER IN
TWENTY NINETEEN ONLY 16% OF
CHILDREN RECEIVED A SUMMER
MEAL. FOOD BANKS ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF CHILD HUNGER
EVERY TIME SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED
FOR BREAKS OR UNANTICIPATED
DISASTERS. AND WE SUPPORT THE
VISION OUTLINED BY CD WE LEARN
THE PANDEMIC THAT THE BEST
POLICY IS TO ENSURE THAT GRAB
AND GO MEALS ARE AVAILABLE AS
WELL AS SCHOOL MEAL REPLACEMENT
B. B. T. BENEFITS AND I'VE SENT
INFORMATION FROM. THE NATIONAL
EMERSON CONGRESSIONAL HUNGER
CENTER FELLOW THAT WE WERE
PROUD TO HOST WE SPOKE WITH
FOURTEEN HUNDRED LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
OVERWHELMINGLY LAST NEXT ASIAN
AMERICAN WHO SPOKE TO THE NEED
FOR THAT BOTH AND APPROACH.
FINALLY GRANTS ARE THE BEST WAY
TO INVEST IN SCHOOL MEALS%
SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA'S
INCREDIBLE FARMERS IN OUR FOOD
ECONOMY HELPING OUR SCHOOLS AND
TO PURCHASE ENTER SCHOOL
NUTRITION WORKFORCE YOUR
PARENTS SERVE FRESH HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA GROWN FOODS WHAT A
POWERFUL TRIPLE WIN. TO CREATE
JOBS IMPROVE HEALTH AND FIGHT
HUNGER. LAST PARENTS OF HUNGRY
KIDS CANNOT SAVE FOR A RAINY
DAY THEY HAVE TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION WE NEED THE STATE TO DO
THE SAME. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION BOTH PROPOSALS.
OR HUNGER HE FUTURE FOR OUR
CHILDREN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REALLY OF- YOUR COM. THAT
COMPLETES THE PANEL
PRESENTATIONS FOR THE FIRST
ITEM AND I WAS GOING TO THE TO
IN A MINUTE ASK IF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE A QUESTION IN
ANY WAY FOR MS ORTIZ BUT LET ME
JUST SAY THAT- THAT I WAS GOING
TO ASK ABOUT WHAT IT WAS LIKE
AND SHE ANSWERED THAT SO WELL
DURING HER. PRESENTATION I
DON'T THINK THERE'S A NEED TO
PASS A QUESTION AND SECONDLY I
THINK KELLI GARNER OF FOR THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SPOKESMAN WRONGLY ABOUT THE
ROLE OF FOOD SERVICE WORKERS
AND I THINK JENNIFER LEBAR MADE
A STATEMENT THAT. ARE COULD NOT
BE EQUAL BY ANY OF US IN TERMS
OF THAT TRIBUTE TO NOT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT AND SO I DON'T
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS EXCEPT TO
THANK HER FOR BEING HERE AND I
WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES IF YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR DEBORAH
ORTIZ. SENATOR GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
THE- PANELS OF SPEAKING THIS
MORNING IN TAKING TIME OUT TO
COME IS GIVE YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
FOR THE FOR THE INFORMATION I
DID HAVE A QUESTION- FOR
DEBORAH- MISTER TEE'S FIRST OF
ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
SERVICE THAT YOU PROVIDED THIS
PAST YEAR AND I COULD SEE THAT
COMMITMENT IN THE HEART YOU
HAVE FOUR CHILDREN AND MAKING
SURE THAT THEIR NEEDS ARE MET-
I ABSOLUTELY EMPATHIZE WITH YOU
AND- I HAVE TO SAY I WAS ONE OF
THOSE. PEOPLE THAT WERE
VOLUNTEERING AND I'M- HANDING
OUT LUNCHES LAST SUMMER IN THE
MIDDLE HE'S OUTSIDE IN THE
PARKING LOT- AND- HAVING GREAT
JOY. AND JUST I HAVE TO SAY IT
WAS SO. WONDERFUL TO SEE THE
FACES OF OUR KIDS. HOME I HAD
NOT SEEN. FOR WELL IN THE
SUMMER PROGRAM THREE MONTHS AND
TO SEE THEM. GOING THROUGH THE
LINE WITH THEIR FAMILIES WAS
JUST AN ABSOLUTE JOY TO SEE
THOSE FAMILIES THAT I RECOGNIZE
IN THOSE KIDS THAT I RECOGNIZE
IS. JUST ABSOLUTELY JOIN FOR A
LOT OF US. I DO HAVE A QUESTION
WITH REGARDS TO SOME OF THE
CONDITIONS IN WHICH YOU WERE
WORKING. I'M INCLUDING AS- THE
PAY AND- THE DAYS THAT YOU SAID
THAT YOU WERE- THAT YOU DON'T
GET ENTITLED FOR WORKING
THROUGH THE MONTH OF. DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS. ARE THOSE
ELEMENTS THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE NEGOTIATED WITHIN- AT THE
LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE NEEDS ARE BEING
MET OR THOSE DEMANDS ARE BEING
THAT ARE NEGOTIATED WITH. IT'S
NOT CONTRACTED TIME FOR US LIKE
I SAID MOST. SERVICE EMPLOYEES
ARE TEN MONTH EMPLOYEES SO THE
EXTRA TWO MONTHS ARE GOING ON A
TIME SHEET. SO WORLDLY ACCRUING
THE BENEFITS OF SICK LEAVE
DURING CONTRACTED TIME. SO IT
IS SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE- SOME FOOD SERVICE
POSITIONS BECOME TWELFTH MONTH
POSITIONS. BECAUSE I DON'T SEE
SOME REPEATING GOING AWAY
ANYTIME SOON. SO IN THE
THIRTEEN YEARS THAT I'VE WORKED
FOR THE SCHOOL DISTRICT I HAVE
WORKED EVERY SUMMER. AND HAVE
NEVER QUITE SICKLY FOR THE
MONTHS THAT I WORKED DURING THE
SUMMER. SO MY QUESTION AND I'M
SORRY I LET ME SEE IF I CAN.
PHRASE IT A DIFFERENT WAY I'M
TO BE MORE CLEARLY- AND- WITH
REGARDS TO WHAT I'M I'M I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. EVEN AND
I UNDERSTAND THAT THOSE ARE
THOSE COUNTRIES ARE TEN MONTHS
BUT FOR THE MINES WERE YOU'RE
CONTRACTED TO WORK FOR THOSE
TWO MONTHS. IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE NEGOTIATED AND- AND
EXPRESSED AT THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT AS FAR AS THE TERMS
AND WHAT BENEFITS YOU RECEIVE.
DURING THOSE TWO MONTHS. I'M I
WOULD LIKE TO TRY I KNOW THAT
WE ARE PUTTING SOME. AT STUFF
WRITING FOR NEGOTIATIONS TO SEE
IF WE CAN GET SOME TEN MONTH
POSITIONS TURNED INTO A TWELVE
MONTH POSITION- BUT I HONESTLY
DON'T KNOW- ECHOED WELL ENOUGH
TO TELL YOU IF THE DISTRICT CAN
GET AROUND IT BY SAYING IT'S
NOT CONTRACTED TIME. OR IF IT'S
YOU KNOW SOMETHING THAT WOULD
HAVE TO BE JUST NEGOTIATED. SO
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN ADDRESSED IN THE PAST AS
FAR AS WE'RE LOOKING OUT FOR
THAT CONDITIONS IN WHICH WE ASK
OUR- OF OUR OUR OUR- BEING-
NEGOTIATED OR CONTRACTED WITH
FOR THE SUMMER. YEAH I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW I CAN'T ANSWER THAT
YOU WOULD HAVE TO TALK TO
SOMEBODY MAYBE A HIGHER UP AND
CSEA THE ANSWER THAT I DON'T
KNOW IF IT- MAKES A DIFFERENCE
THAT PEOPLE ARE THEY TAKE
BASICALLY- IF THEY PUT OUT
INTEREST FORMS SO I MEAN YOU
DON'T HAVE TO WORK. SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT HAVING A CHOICE
MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN WHETHER
OR NOT YOU GET THE BENEFITS ARE
NOT JUST IT DOESN'T SEEM
EQUITABLE TO ME THAT I DON'T
GET THE BENEFIT OF BEING A
TWELVE MONTH EMPLOYED BY AND
WORKING TWELVE MONTHS. TEN I
THINK JENNIFER LEBAR RAISED HER
HAND IS THAT BECAUSE YOU WOULD
LIKE TO HELP. ANSWER THAT
QUESTION. YES PLEASE DO OKAY
THANK YOU. SO THESE ARE. IT
THEY LEAVE IS ASSOCIATED WITH A
NUMBER OF MONTHS THAT YOU ARE
WORKING. AND SO THAT THE WAY
THAT CAN BE RESOLVED IS AROUND
MAKING THESE POSITIONS THAT A
TWELVE MONTH POSITION IF THE
WORK IS. AT AND I THINK THERE
IS A CASE TO BE MADE IN A LOT
OF SITUATIONS WHERE THE JOB IS.
A TWELVE MONTH JOB BUT IT'S
TYPICALLY WHERE THESE ARE TEN
MONTHS JOBS BECAUSE THE SUMMER
SCHOOL DOESN'T GO THE WHOLE THE
WHOLE SUMMER. AND SO THAT'S WHY
I'M- THAT IS DONE BUT I THINK
THERE'S MORE AND MORE BECAUSE
OF THE SITUATION THAT WE'RE IN
AND BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THESE THINGS. THAT SOME 12-1
JOBS CAN BE CREATED AND THAT I
THINK THAT'S WHAT ENDEAVOR IS
ALSO REFERRING TO. AND SO I
THINK THAT'S WHERE THIS CAN BE
MADE I DON'T THINK YOU CAN MAKE
THE CASE FOR ALL. OF THE JOBS
TO BE TWELVE MONTHS. CAN MAKE
THE CASE FOR A NUMBER OF THE
JOBS TO BE TWELVE MONTHS AND SO
THAT'S A THAT'S A CONVERSATION
THAT CAN HAPPEN. BUT I DO NOT
THINK THAT THERE IS THE ABILITY
WITHIN THE AND COACH TO- ADD-
OR TO ACCRUE THE TEN MONTHS BUT
I THINK IT'S ALSO GOING TO VARY
FROM SCHOOL DISTRICT TO SCHOOL
DISTRICT. IN HANDING ON WHAT
THE SITUATION IS AT THAT SCHOOL
SO IT IS A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT- YES PROVOCATIVE. YES
OKAY. PERFECT SECOND PLEASE.
YOUR QUESTION SENATOR MAN.
THANK YOU- LAST I JUST TO FIRST
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR CUSTOMER.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A AND-
IMPORTANT- AS YOU ARE
ELOQUENTLY DESCRIBED- IT'S HARD
TO EXPECT OUR STUDENTS TO LEARN
WHEN THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
WHETHER AND EMAILS COMING FROM
AND- FOOD INSECURITIES
UNFORTUNATELY RAMPANT ACROSS
THE STATE- I WANTED TO ASK MR
KEYES. YOU'RE ON THE GROUND AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THE STATE. HAS
YOU KNOW SOME INCREDIBLE IDEAS
ON. HOW TO DE STIGMATIZE- THESE
LUNCHES HOW TO GET. PEOPLE TO
TAKE THEM OUT BUT WE STILL HAVE
A HUGE GAP IN. FOOD INSECURITY
AND NUMBER STUDENTS THAT ARE
TAKING THIS SO. IF IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE WHAT CAN WE DO TO
TRY TO INCREASE TAKE UP WHAT
CAN WE DO TO GET MORE STUDENTS
A COMMON. ACTUALLY PICK UP
THESE MEALS. IT I IT'S REALLY
UP. THAT THERE'S CHOICE AND
STATE- I KNOW OUR OPTIONS FOR
WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PUT
INTO THE LUNCHES GRAB AND GO
STYLE. I HAVE BEEN A LIMITING
FACTOR- I CAN TELL YOU THAT
DEPENDING ON WHAT IS IN THE
BACK MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE ON
IF THE KIDS TAKE THE BACK- SO
JUST. GOOD FOOD OPTIONS LIKE
KNOW FRESH THE FIRST. YOU KNOW
FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM AND
GETTING. GETTING GOOD QUALITY
INGREDIENTS INTO THE LUNCHES I
THINK THIS IS CRITICAL. ONE OF
THE MOST POPULAR OPTIONS. M.
WELL IT'S HARD RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS BEEN COLD
SO WE'RE DEALING WITH THE COLD
FOOD IN THE KIDS DEFINITELY DO
YOU PREFER A HOT OPTIONS IN OUR
DISTRICT SO IF THEY DO GO BACK
TO- YOU KNOW PUTTING A HOT ITEM
THEN I MEAN SOME OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN GIVING-
THAT'S FROZEN AND THEY TAKE IT
HOME FOR EXAMPLE- THEY'RE NOT
AS INCLINED TO TAKE AND I DON'T
THINK WHEN IT'S FROZEN BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T MUCH ON ON THE WAY
HOME. SO HAVING SOMETHING THAT
YOU KNOW THEY CAN JUST. AARON
TO BECAUSE THEY'RE HUNGRY- IS A
GOOD THING THEY LIKE SANDWICHES
THEY LIKE BURGERS YOU KNOW AND
LOVE PIZZA. BEGINNING A PRESENT
SLICE OF PIZZA IS DEFINITELY
NOT AS APPEALING AS GETTING A
NICE. WARM SMELLS GOOD LOOKS
GOOD HE SAID HE SAID THAT YOU
CAN EAT. THEIR KIDS BASICALLY.
THERE CAN'T YEAH. WELL THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISS. THIRTY THREE
SHARES YOU'RE WELCOME. THAT'S
YOU BETTER THE IT'S- TO A-
CENTER REMAINED TO. THAT TO
KIDS AS IF ADULTS WOULD NOT
WANT. TO REFERENCE AND PEOPLE.
SENATOR A JOB. I DO HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS AS WELL
AND- UNDERSTANDING. IS THERE
ANY- INCINERATION AND- I'M NOT
SURE WHAT HAS BEEN DONE TO
ACCOMMODATE SPECIALLY FOR
TALKING ABOUT UNIVERSAL
BREAKFAST AND LUNCHES HAS THERE
BEEN ANY ACCOMMODATIONS OR
ANYTHING OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
REGARD TO FOOD SENSITIVITIES-
AND DIET RESTRICTIONS FOR MANY
OF OUR CHILDREN AND HOW DO YOU
IMPLEMENT BETTER WORK THAT IN
IN THE MATTER THAT YOU FOLKS
ARE MOVING FORWARD WITH THE
UNIVERSAL WITH MEAL PLANS AND
THEN SECOND TO THAT AND I'LL
JUST FOLLOW UP BECAUSE I'M NOT
SURE. WHO WOULD BE THE BEST
PERSON TO ANSWER BUT THEN- WITH
REGARDS TO- OF COURSE PLANNING-
AND- TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
MANY CHILDREN YOU'RE GOING TO
BE FEEDING THE COST OF THAT IN
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE MEALS THAT
ARE NOT BEING UTILIZED OR THE
FUNDS THEY'RE NOT BEING
UTILIZED. TO ADAM. TO COMEDY
THAT DAY ALL OF THE CHILDREN IN
THE SCHOOL IN A LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. IN WHICH THAT
DIRECTED TO MS ORTIZ. I'M I
DON'T I'M NOT SURE ABOUT MR
TEAS BUT I BELIEVE THAT IT
MIGHT BE THE THING IS. IT I
WANNA. I WANNA GET TO THAT BUT
SHE HAS A HARD STOP OF FIVE
MINUTES FROM NOW SO I WAS JUST
TRYING TO DO THE FIRST
QUESTIONS DIRECTED TO HER SO
THAT. THAT WE COVERED AND IF
YOU'RE DONE WITH THOSE
QUESTIONS OF HER AND SHE WAS
OUR TEAS COULD ANSWER THAT MR
JEEZ I'LL BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
GIVE WHAT WAS GOING TO BE ONE
OF MY GLOBAL QUESTIONS HEADING
OKAY. AND SO WE WILL NOT LET IT
DROP OKAY. BUT I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HONOR MISS
ORTIZ'S TIME BEFORE SHE HAD TO
GO ABSENT ANYTHING ELSE FOR MS
ORTIZ. THEN LET ME FOR YOU FOR
BEING HERE AND STAY AS LONG AS
YOU CAN BUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU HAVE TO GO TO WORK IN A FEW
MINUTES. AND WEBER. AND IF YOU
ARE STILL HERE. AND THERE
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO SAY JUST
RAISE YOUR HAND BUT THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR BEING HERE AND TO WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU DO.
THANK YOU. AND THEN LET ME. GO
TO THE TOP OF THE GLOBAL
QUESTIONS. A. N. N. MAKE LET ME
MAKE A COMMENT FIRST
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE OF- I
THINK. ANDREW MADE A POINT THAT
I WANTED TO MAKE IT THE OPENING
WHICH IS THAT WE ARE TALKING
HERE. ABOUT SCHOOL NUTRITION.
pWHAT WE CAN DO IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE SUB COMMITTEE. HOWEVER
THE EFFORTS THAT ARE BROADER
THAN WHAT WE DO HERE.
DEFINITELY IMPACT THIS
DISCUSSION AND DOUBLE. AND
DEFINITELY IMPACT WHETHER WE
CAN MEET THE NUTRITION NEEDS OF
KIDS. AND WITH SPECIFIC
REFERENCE THE ONE THING HE
SAID- ARM. ROUGHLY A MONTH AGO
I WENT. TO THE FOOD
DISTRIBUTION OF SECOND HARVEST
AT THE FAIRGROUNDS IN SANTA
CRUZ AND WATSONVILLE. I WAS
JUST FLOORED AT HOW LONG THE
LINES WERE. AND THEY ARE- DAY
PASSED SOME OF THEM IF THEY
WOULD BE WILLING TO TALK TO ME.
AND I SPEAK SPANISH AND A LOT
OF THE MORE SPANISH SPEAKING.
OF PEOPLE GETTING FOOD. AND IT
WAS PEOPLE THAT HAD BEEN
WORKING IN THE FIELDS OR HAD
BEEN WORKING IN THE PACKING
SHEDS OR HAD BEEN WORKING IN
GENERAL THERE WERE KIDS IN THE
CAR THAT WE'RE PICKING UP THE
FOOD WITH THEM CONCERT WAS
REALLY CLEAR. THAT FOOD
INSECURITY WAS WAS BROAD AND I
AM AWARE HAVING WORKED WITH THE
FOOD BANK IN IN SANTA CRUZ IN
RECENT YEARS VERY CLOSELY. THAT
AS HE SAID THERE'S ONE
PARTICULAR GROUP. OF OAXACAN
IMMIGRANTS MANY OF WHOM ARE NOT
DOCUMENTED. THAT ARE AFRAID. TO
DO ANYTHING IN PUBLIC IN THE
FOOD BANK HAS FIGURED OUT WAYS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE FOOD IN SECURITY IN THAT
SO. THERE ARE EFFORTS THAT ARE
MUCH BROADER THAN WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY THAT ARE
THAT ARE BEING DONE AND- A. N.
IN A SHAMELESS PLUG- THE THING
THAT IT BECAUSE MY FIRST
QUESTION IS GOING TO BE ALONG
THE LINES OF. SENATOR JOE BOGGS
WHICH IS WHAT THE DROP OFF IS
BEEN. CUT DURING THE PANDEMIC
OF PEOPLE UTILIZING IT AND HOW
THAT IS FIT TO FUNDING. BECAUSE
THE ONE PLACE THAT'S BEEN OFF
THE CHARTS IS FOOD BANKS ARE
AND THERE IS AN ASK IN SUB
THREE. TO CONTINUE THE BOXED
FOODS AND OTHER THINGS AND THE
NATIONAL GUARD ASSISTANCE
EXPIRES. IN A MATTER OF WEEKS
AND THE NATIONAL GUARD HAS MADE
IT HAPPEN IN SOME PLACES IN THE
STATE SO. THERE ARE QUESTIONS
THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT WE DO
HERE WILL HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED
ON FOOD INSECURITY IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THAT THEY
ARE BECAUSE THERE SHOULD NOT BE
A FOOD CLIFF. OR A SERVICE.
THAT FOOD BANKS GO OVER IN JUNE
WHEN SCHOOLS AREN'T TOTALLY
BACK. AND STILL MIGHT BE
OFFERING AT A SUBNORMAL LEVELS
OF PARTICIPATION. SO THAT WE
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT WE
REACH KIDS AND FAMILIES UNTIL
WE'RE AT A PLACE THAT. WE MIGHT
RE OPEN AND BE IN A MORE EVEN
LEVEL SO I JUST SORT OF WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. SO THAT WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT. WHAT THE SCHOOL
NUTRITION ISSUES ARE AND HOW TO
REACH PEOPLE FOR THAT WE KNOW
THAT IT'S A LITTLE BROADER THAN
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE TALKING
ABOUT SO. LET ME JUST START UP-
AN CRIB IN PART FROM SENATOR OR
CHOI BOGUE AND I DON'T KNOW WHO
IS THE BEST. BUT TO ASK BUT I'M
JUST WORKING EVERYBODY TALKED
ABOUT. WHAT THE PROGRAM IS AND
HOW IT WORKED OR NOT WORKED
DURING THE PANDEMIC WHAT WHAT'S
THE IMPACT OF THE PANDEMIC
BITTEN WHAT WHAT'S THE RATE OF
PARTICIPATION. OF OUR STUDENTS
IN GETTING THIRD THE TAKEOUT OR
COMING TO THE SCHOOL AND
PICKING UP MALES AS OPPOSED TO
THE NORMAL LEVEL OF
PARTICIPATION IS THERE ANYBODY
THAT FEELS LIKE THEY CAN SPEAK
TO THAT. CHAIR ALIGNER FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I'D BE
HAPPY TO. TO JUMP IN A LITTLE
THAT. YES ABSOLUTELY DON'T POSE.
THANK YOU. I'M ASSUMING TWENTY
NINETEEN THE USDA RELEASED A
NATIONAL COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT TITLED SCHOOLS
NUTRITION AND MEALS COST STUDY
THE STUDY REPORTED THAT ON
AVERAGE- ALL SCHOOLS REVENUES-
FOR MEMBERS. EXCUSE ME REVENUES
FROM REIMBURSABLE LUNCHES
COVERED ONLY AN AVERAGE OF 93%
REPORTED COSTS AND REVENUES
FROM BREAKFAST COVERED 82% IN
CALIFORNIA WE KNOW THAT A
STARKLY ABOUT 40% OF OUR
SCHOOLS PARTICIPATING IN THE
FEDERAL MEALS PROGRAM ENCROACH
ON THEIR DISTRICTS GENERAL FUND
TO HELP SUPPORT THEIR FOOD
SERVICE. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THE PANDEMIC FURTHER STRESS THE
PHYSICAL PHYSICAL HEALTH OF
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS BUT
THE PROBLEM FOR US IS THAT WE
DON'T KNOW THE OVERALL IMPACT
WE THINK ABOUT A 30% DROP IN
MEALS SERVED DURING THE
PANDEMIC WHICH DIRECTLY IMPACTS
THOSE REIMBURSEMENTS AND OF
COURSE- AND INCREASED COSTS FOR
PERSONNEL AND DIFFERENT
EQUIPMENT WERE HUGE COSTS THAT
WERE ASSOCIATED WITH WHAT
HAPPENS FOR THE SCHOOL FISCAL
HEALTH IN PROVIDING THESE MEALS
AND IN THE ABILITY OF SCHOOLS
TO CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE. SO
DO YOU IN EFFECT NO THERE'S
BEEN A 30% REDUCTION BECAUSE
YOU'VE DEDUCED IT FROM A 30%
DROP IN CLAIMS FOR MEALS IS
THAT HOW YOU GOT TO THAT THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY IN. ARE WE NOT
THINK. HE'S NORMALLY JUST A
QUESTIONS AT THE POOL FOR LET
ME ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY THAT
WANTS TO ADD TO THAT AND THEN
I'M JUST GONNA GO TO CENTER.
BOOK IS THERE ANYBODY THAT
WANTS TO ADD TO THAT. SAYING NO
ONE ARE WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS GO
TO THE TWO SENATORS AND THEN
ALL BACK CLEAN UP IF THERE IS.
ANYTHING LEFT ALL DO THAT BUT
CENTER GROVE JOB YOU STARTED TO
GO INTO SOME OF THESE ISSUES-
I'D RECOGNIZE YOU TO GO
WHEREVER YOU WANT WITH
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYERED I WAS JUST- I I'M JUST
A CURIOUS TO. TO SEE- CAN I
HEAR WHAT THE PLAN WILL BE OR
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE PLANET.
THAT YOU HAVE WITH REGARDS TO.
MEETING THAT. THE NUMBERS. OF
STUDENTS THAT NEED TO BE-
COVERED AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN FINANCIALLY WITH THE
RESOURCES OF THOSE THAT ARE NOT
BEING UTILIZED- MAXIMIZED I'M
JUST ANYTHING IF THERE'S WILL
THERE BE POTENTIALLY ANY EXTRA
FUNDING THAT HAPPENS FROM
SCHOOLS OR STUDENTS NOT TAKING
PART IN THE SERVICES OF THE OF
THE MEALS OR- IF WE'RE NOT
PURCHASING I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT DO YOU FOLKS PURCHASE THAT
THE MEALS FOR EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT AND THEN THERE UTILIZED
OR NOT UTILIZED OR DO YOU. HOW
DOES THAT WORK FINANCIALLY AND
IS DIRECTING THE QUESTION AND I
BELIEVE. THAT WOULD BE. TO
SARAH CORTEZ OR EVEN PROBABLY-
AT SEA. KIM FRENZAL. YES
TEMPERANCE ALL DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- I CAN START THAT MAN
SERAPHINE LIKE TO. I'M IN THE
FEDERAL MAIL PROGRAMS OUR
REIMBURSEMENT AND SERVICE FOR
ACTUAL MEALS SERVED- AND SO IT
REALLY OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
DEPEND ON THE STUDENT
PARTICIPATION SO THAT THEY CAN
SUBMIT THEIR MAIL CLAIMS IN THE
REPAIRS TO BE REIMBURSED FOR
THE ACTUAL MEALS THAT WERE
PROVIDED TO THE STUDENTS SO
WHEN WE SEE THE DROP AND
REIMBURSEMENT SO THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC WITHIN A 30% DROP. IN
REIMBURSEMENTS THAT TELLS US
THAT WHEN WE KNOW AND JENNIFER
CAN ABSOLUTELY SPEAK OF THIS
THAT- THEY HAVE THEY HAVE FIXED
COSTS THAT CONTINUE AND WHEN
THEY SEE THEIR MALE COUNTER
MAIL CLAIMING GO DOWN THERE
THEIR REVENUE IS GOING DOWN TO
SUPPORT THEIR PRO. BUT JUST LET
ME ASK QUICK FOLLOW UP BEFORE
CENTER BROKEN AND YOU TALKED
ABOUT FIX COSTS SO. REVENUES
MIGHT GO DOWN THE PARTICIPATION
MIGHT GO DOWN BUT THE FIXED
COSTS ARE STEADY IS THAT WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. YES AND I THINK
WE WENT TO- IT AGAIN JENNIFER
CAN REALLY TALK. REAL LIFE TO
ALL OF THIS- BUT YOU'LL ALSO
YOUNG THROUGH THE PANDEMIC WE
SAW FOOD COSTS GO UP THE
PACKAGING SOME OF THE
EQUIPMENT. A STAFF SCHEDULES
AND MAYBE NEED MORE STAFF TO
COVER MORE POINTS TO SELL JUST
TO KEEP EVERYBODY- HEALTHY AND
SAFE AND SO THEY DID SEE. YOUR
DIFFERENT COST AS WELL CHANGING
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC. IN IN
SENATOR ENOUGH I CAN ASK JUST A
CLARIFYING QUESTION IS. ARE YOU
ASKING IT YOU KNOW IN THE EVENT
THAT WE DO ARE ABLE TO MOVE
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL MEALS WELL
WHEN IMPLEMENTATION LOOK LIKE.
YES FOR THAT YES SO WE WERE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
UNIVERSAL ONE BECAUSE I KNOW
WE'RE SUPPORTING AT SUCH A
MEASURE I GUESS I WAS.
PREVIOUSLY NINE IN A PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE. BUT AS WE SUPPORT
PROGRAM SUCH AS AS THAT
UNIVERSAL. AND WE'RE LOOKING
AT- TRYING TO FIND SUCH A
PROGRAM OF COURSE THE NUMBERS
WILL VERY NOT EVERY AND AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER EARLIER NOT
EVERY SCHOOL DISTRICT
PARTICIPATES IN THAT AND I'M
ASSUMING. IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
FOR THAT UNIVERSAL PART IN
FEDERAL. YOU NEED TO HAVE EVERY
SCHOOL DISTRICT- PARTICIPATING
SO MY CONCERNED OR NOT
CONCERNED I. I GUESS I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND. HOW DO WE
WERE THAT FINE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE COVER THOSE COSTS IF
FEDERAL EITHER GOING TO BE
COMING IN AND SUPPLEMENTING
THOSE EXTRA FIXED COSTS TO
ACCOMMODATE. THE UNIVERSAL YOU
PROGRAM OR IS THAT A STATE
RESPONSIBILITY SO WILL THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BE ABLE. TO
SUPPLEMENT THAT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS COVERED IN ORDER
TO PURSUE THAT ENDEAVOR OR IS
THAT A RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE. AND IF THAT'S THE CASE-
IS THERE A POSSIBILITY IN THE
FORMULA IN THE WAY THAT IT'S-
STRUCTURED RIGHT NOW TO HAVE.
EXTRA FUNDS ARE AVAILABLE AT
THE END IS OUR POSSIBILITY FOR
THAT WHICH I'M I'M ASSUMING
BECAUSE OF WHAT YOU SAID THAT
IT'S IN ARREARS YOU YOU BAIL
BASED ON WHAT YOU YOU. YOU
SERVE THAT WOULD NOT BE THE
POSSIBILITY BUT AT THE STATE
LEVEL IS THERE A POSSIBILITY TO
HAVE EXTRA FUNDS AT THE VERY
END. REGARDING YEAH. MATTER FOR
ELLIE TO DATE. YOU CAN
CERTAINLY TALK ABOUT MORE ABOUT
LIKE HOW WE WORK THE OPERATIONS
ON A DAILY BASIS. BUT I THINK
WHEN IT COMES TO LIKE THE
ACTUAL FUNDING ASPECT OF IT AND
HOW WE WOULD IMPLEMENT THIS ON
A STATEWIDE LEVEL IT'S BETTER
FOR OUR LEAD TO M. OR SCARED TO
TAKE THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU
JENNIFER. GARNER WITH THE STATE
FOR THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. IT REFER TO
SOME OR SOME OF THE EARLIER
COMMENTS THAT WE NEED WE
BELIEVE THAT TO PROVIDE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL STUDENTS
RECEIVE THESE MEALS. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
AT THE CALIFORNIA UNIVERSAL
MEAL PROGRAM REQUIRE ALL
SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE- BECAUSE
THERE IS THAT. THERE IS AN
INCREASE REIMBURSEMENTS FOR ALL
SCHOOLS THE STATE MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT IS TWENTY FOUR
CENTS WHILE THE MEAL FOR A
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR A
FREE MEAL IS THREE DOLLARS AND
SIXTY CENTS WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS WOULD INCENTIVIZE FOR
SCHOOLS THAT DON'T. CURRENTLY
PARTICIPATE- THERE BECAUSE THEY
DO STILL HAVE TO PROVIDE THOSE
MEALS. IN ADDITION IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE NEED
TO DRAW DOWN THE FEDERAL FUNDS
FIRST AND THEN SUPPLEMENT WITH
STATE DOLLARS RATHER THAN
SUPPLANTING WITH STATE DOLLARS
TO PULLING DOWN THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS. WHAT AT WOULD
MITIGATE HOW MUCH THE COST TO
THE STATE. GENERAL FUND WITH A-
SO- IT ELLIE RIGHT ELLIE. YES
DALY YES SORRY EIGHT SERVICE
SIMILAR HEAD OF CRISTINA GO
HEAD GO OF JUST SO QUICKLY I
GOT FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
CALL. SO I APPRECIATE THAT THAT
STATEMENT- ON THAT WHAT WOULD
BE THE REASON FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS NOT TO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE MOVING FORWARD.
IT'S A PAPERWORK BATTLE A LOT
OF TIMES FOR SCHOOLS THAT DON'T
HAVE A HIGH LOW INCOME LOW
INCOME POPULATION THE PAPER
WORK TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN CAN BE DIFFICULT AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT WE
DO NEED TO INCENTIVIZE THIS-
LET ME GRAB MY NOTES REALLY
QUICKLY BECAUSE I HAVE A LITTLE
BIT MORE INFORMATION ON THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT I COVER
EVERYTHING- AS I MENTIONED
THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED SOMETHING.
PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND FOUR HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY TWO CHARTER SCHOOLS
THAT DON'T PARTICIPATE IN THE
CURRENT FEDERAL SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS IT'S BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE COMMUNITIES WITH
LOW POPULATIONS HAVEFREE AND
REDUCED MEALS- ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS AND THE L. A. PREFERS
TO COVER THE COST OF THE
CALIFORNIA STEEL THIS IS STATE
MEAL MANDATE FOR NEEDY STUDENTS
THEMSELVES. SOME SCHOOLS DO SAY
THAT THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN
OF OPERATING FEDERAL THE
FEDERAL PROGRAM IS NOT WORTH
THE LITTLE REIMBURSEMENT THAT
THEY RECEIVE CURRENTLY SOME USE
NON FEDERAL FUNDS TO PROVIDE
MEALS TO NEEDY STUDENTS AND
SOME PARTNER WITH NEIGHBORING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROVIDE MEALS.
BUT THE ADMINISTRATIVE. IS TO
COMPLY WITH FEDERAL PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL AS A
SECOND LAYER OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIFIC LAWS THAT MAKE PROGRAM
OPERATION DIFFICULT. AND THEY
CAN BE SUBJECT TO SOME PROGRAM
INTEGRITY CONTROLS. THIS WOULD
BE DIFFERENT UNDER A UNIVERSAL
MEALS PROGRAM AS IMPLEMENTED BY
THE STATE. ON THAT WOULD SPLIT
THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
BARRIERS SO UNIVERSAL STATE.
WOULD DEFINITELY MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THESE FIVE HUNDRED AND PLUS
SCHOOLS. DO YOU HAVE A LESS
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND
THEREFORE BE MORE INCENTIVIZED
TO BE PARTICIPANTS. I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT WOULD NECESSARILY
DECREASE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN BUT WHAT IT WOULD DO IS
INCREASE THE REIMBURSEMENT THAT
THEY'RE ELIGIBLE FOR RIGHT NOW
IF THEY'RE NOT PARTICIPATING IN
THE NATIONAL PROGRAM THE ONLY
GET TWENTY FOUR CENTS- FROM THE
STATE. FOR THESE FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS IF THEY'RE
PARTICIPATING THEY'RE GETTING
THREE DOLLARS AND SIXTY CENTS
FOR THOSE NEEDY STUDENT MEALS
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING. SO THAT
WOULD BE AN INCENTIVE. YES YEAH
OKAY ALL RIGHT PERFECT THANK
YOU. NOT COMPLETE YOUR
QUESTIONS SEND GOVERNMENT. YEAH
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT
LINE OF QUESTIONING JUST A
LITTLE BIT- I GUESS I'VE HEARD
THAT THE CONTENT OF THE MEALS
IS A FACTOR IN INCREASING TAKE
UP FROM STUDENTS AND THEN- THE
PAPERWORK AND REDUCING
PAPERWORK IS A FACTOR IN.
GETTING SCHOOLS TO PARTICIPATE
WHAT OTHER. OBSTACLES COULD
TAKE UP AND PARTICIPATION BOTH
BY ELEAZAR SCHOOLS AND BY
STUDENTS. DO ANY OF OUR
PANELISTS SEE THAT WE COULD BE
ADDRESSING. DID YOU DRESS THAT
IS. I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT IS
ADEQUATE TIME TO EAT AND
REALLY- I THINK MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE THOSE
FRESH MEALS AND I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE ALSO
ADDRESSING WITHIN THIS BILL AS
WELL. AT. SURE THAT WE HAVE
TRAINING FOR OUR STAFF AND I
THINK IF WE'RE AND DOING ALL
THESE THINGS TOGETHER WITH THIS
BILL WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES HAVE ANYTHING THAT.
OKAY- I'M OF ON MY NEXT
QUESTION AND- I THINK YOU ALL
SPOKE TO THE SUMMER DROP OFF
BEING 30% AND I WOULD JUST ECHO
A POINT THE CHEERLEADER MADE-
WHEN I'VE BEEN OUT OF MY
DISTRICT AT DIFFERENT TO
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS- WE HAVE
SEEN JUST LINES AND LINES OF
CARS SO I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THAT 30% DROP OFF JUST BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF FOLKS THAT STOP
TAKING IS PROBABLY LOW BALLING
IT. MY EXPERIENCE AND I THINK
OTHER SENATORS HAVE SEEN THIS
AS WELL IN THEIR DISTRICTS- IS
THAT PROBABLY THE COVE IT
IMPACTS ON OUR ECONOMY HAVE
REALLY DRIVEN UP DRAMATICALLY
THAT THE NEED FOR FOOD AND THE
AMOUNT OF FOOD INSECURITY- BY I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS THIS IF WE
DO A RETURN TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION IN THE FALLS I
THINK WE'RE ALL EXPECTING-
WHAT. WILL HAPPEN IS IF WE SEE
A MASSIVE SEARCH- AS IT MIGHT
BE THE CASE IN THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN NEED OF
REDUCED PRICE OR FREE LUNCHES-
COULD IT BE THE CASE THAT FIXED
COSTS COULD GO UP IF WE SEE A
DRAMATIC RISE IN. DEMAND AND I
GUESS THAT'S THE QUESTION. FOR
ALLEY GARNER. YOU SENATE. IN
THE CASE. THIS HAS. WE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN WITH. AT PROJECTED
BECAUSE WITHIN. OF TWENTY PER
PER TO. SO THAT IS PART OF THE
CALCULATION THAT WE HAVE BEEN
DOING. IN PRIDE. TRYING TO
PROVIDE SOME COST. ANALYSIS FOR
THIS THIS PROGRAM WE DO BELIEVE
THAT THERE WILL BE AN INCREASE
IN PARTICIPATION. AND SO WERE
FACTORING IN A 20%
PARTICIPATION INCREASED INTO
COST ANALYSIS 20% OVER THE
BASELINE THAT WE SAW PRETENDING
TO. YES SIR OKAY GOT IT- AND
THEN I GUESS YOU KNOW THIS IS
MAYBE MORE BASIC QUESTION BUT-
YOU KNOW IF WE DO RETURN TO IN
PERSON INSTRUCTION WHAT DO WE
HAVE PLANS FOR A LITTLE BIT
PROTOCOLS AROUND FOOD
PREPARATION AND DISTRIBUTION I
ASSUME WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO.
RETURN THE HOT MEALS IN. THERE
IS THAT GONNA BE LEFT UP TO
LOCAL CONTROLLERS THAT
SOMETHING IN YOUR VIEW. THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
APARTMENT EDUCATION SHOULD
WEIGH IN ON I GUESS THAT'S A
QUESTION FOR. EITHER MISTER
CHAIN OR MISS LAVAR. OR ANYONE
ELSE WHO HAS AN OPINION ON THIS.
I'M I THINK WE'RE PLANNING ON
DOING IN IN SAN FRANCISCO TO
RETURN TO HOT MEALS AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY DOING IT RIGHT NOW I
THINK THE QUESTION IS GOING TO
BE WHAT MODALITY WE'RE GOING TO
BE STIRRING THOSE MEALS WILL IT
BE I AM IN OUR- CONTINUING WITH
MEALS IN THE CLASSROOM- AND
DELEM. LEVEL OR GRABBING GOES
SERVICE AT THE CENTER LEVEL OR
WILL WE BE ABLE TO RETURN TO
THE CAFETERIA SERVICE I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY QUESTION THAT
WE HAVE TO ANSWER BUT I THINK
THAT WILL BE BASED ON THAT
REALLY THAT PUBLIC HEALTH. AND
THE INDIVIDUAL DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND WHAT THEY
WILL BE DOING I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE LOCAL QUESTION
HAS TO BE ANSWERED. AND I GUESS
ABOUT HER OF THE QUESTION IS
JUST A- SECOND QUESTION WHICH
IS IT WILL WE SEE A- RISE. KERR
BE ON THE NEED FOR COVERED FOR.
IN PARTICLES. I THINK WE WERE
CONTINUE TO SEE THAT RISING.
AND BASED ON P. P. E. REQUIRE.
AT THE- GARFIELD DEBORAH AND- I
MEAN WHERE WE'RE TO CAN TO SEE
THE RAISING COSTS. YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE OF THE PARTICULAR SHE
WE SEEN THAT COSTS AND TROUBLE
FOR US- CAN'T REMEMBER. OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD. BUT CONTINUE
READING- PROVIDE NOW. I THOSE
ARE UNDING IF WE- CONTINUE TO
HAVE. IN THE DISTRICT IS. TO BE
FOR THAT I DON'T. I'M AS TO I
HAVING THAT FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL
USING OUR REMEMBER. THAT WILL
HELP RAISE SOME IS BUT THAT ALL
TO BE. THAT AND I KNOW FOR US
THIS TIME. OUR TERM AS ITS
PUBLIC ORDERS ALLOW MANY- THE
BANKS WOULD- HAVE- MOBILE
PANTRIES THAT WOULD ROLL OUT TO
TWO SCHOOLS HAVING MORE OF A OF
FARMERS MARKET CHOICE. BUT YOU
CAN IMAGINE- YOU KNOW THAT THE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S THE
CONDITIONS ARE SAFE MISSION
FOOD SAFETY AS WELL AS TV AND
OTHER PROTECTIONS- BUT THAT'S
THAT'S THE- THE DOWN THE ROAD
VISION- AND BREAK WE SHOULD THE
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. THE GREAT THING YOU.
AND IF I CAN AND ONE OTHER
THING SO MANY MEN JUST LEARNING
AND IF WE DO CONTINUE WITH IS
OUR WHAT THAT WE DO NOT KNOW
WHAT WE CONTINUE TO NEED TO DO
GROUND GO FOR THIS YEAR THAT
ARE. I AM STAYING DISTANCE SO
THAT ANOTHER SERVICE THAT WE
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE YES
ARE JUST SINCE AND SCHOOLS AS
LIGHT SAN FRANCISCO OR ELSE
DOING YOUR TO DOOR TO PROGRAMS
FOR THOSE FAMILIES ARE ANY TO.
OUR RAM PROBE SO WILL WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE TO GO JULY SIR
ON TOP OF THATIS NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE SIGNED THE BURKE
SO HOW DO WE WILL WE HOW WILL
WE FOR THAT THAT'S ANOTHER
LAYER THAT COMPLEX AS WELL. LET
ME JUST. BEFORE I ASK MY-
QUESTION I APPRECIATE THAT TO.
INTO SHOULD NOT MISS FREE THE
CALM. OF MAY. OR I. WHICH IS
THE WE OVER WHY. X. BILL TO
RETURN IN THE- BUT THERE WOULD
BE OF. IN THE BE SOME MALT AND
I SAW. THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE
BIG NON. BUT DURING THAT YOU
CALL IT THAT BECAUSE WILL HAVE
TALK THAT WOULD WE GET IT IF
THERE ARE. THE CAN FOR ISSUES
SMALL PERCENT THAT. AFFECT
THEMSELVES OF THAT. LET ME JUST
SAY THAT THEIR WORK. IN THE
AGENDA PACKET IN I THINK- IN
THE OPENING STATEMENT IN THE-
FOR. SENATORS BUT CHAU BOCA MEN
THOSE OF REALLY BEEN A DRY WELL
THE THING I LIKE JUST. TALK
ABOUT FOR A BRIEF SECOND A AS
THE I. IS THE SENATE. CAUCUS
BECAUSE- FOR THE ON AND- IN A
FEW PLACES DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
AND SAID WE HAVE. ONE TIME
MONEY OR NEW ON GOING MONEY AND
LET'S BUDGET FOR IMPACT
FORECOURTS TRIED TO ACTUALLY
TAKE CERTAIN ISSUES AND REALLY
TRY TO ADDRESSED AND SO
HOMELESSNESS IS ONE STUDENT NAY
DIDN'T HIGHER EDUCATION IS
ANOTHER. BUT ANOTHER IS THE ONE
THAT FALLS INTO THE PURVIEW OF
THE HEARING TODAY. WHICH IS
SCHOOL NUTRITION AS A TOP
PRIORITY- INCLUDING PROGRESS ON
UNIVERSAL MEALS AND MAXIMIZING
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS AND
BUILDING OFF THE WAIVERS WHICH
MS GARNER COMMENTED ON TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE DO THAT REDUCING
CHILD HUNGER DURING HOLIDAY
BREAKS AND SUMMER BREAKS WHICH
SOME OF OUR- OUR PANELISTS
BURKE COMMENTED ON. REDUCING OR
ELIMINATING SCHOOL MEAL DEBT
FOR ELLIE AS WHICH WAS TALKED
ABOUT. A ALSO INCREASING THE
NEW TO CONTENT OF MEALS AND
LOCAL GROWN IN SCHOOL LUNCHES
THAT WAS ADDRESSED AND THEN
STABILIZING AND SUPPORTING THE
CLASSIFIED STAFF. TO PROVIDE
FOOD SERVICE AT SCHOOLS AND
MISS ORTIZ COMMENTS AND SUNGROW
CHAU BOOKS QUESTIONS GOT IT
THAT SO I WOULD JUST ASK
GLOBALLY. IF YOU WORK FOR. OUR
IF WE WERE AS A STATE TO MOVE
TO UNIVERSAL MALES AND SOME OF
THE OTHER THINGS THAT THAT I
JUST LISTED WHAT DO YOU THINK
ARE THE BARRIERS IF WE MAKE A
COMMITMENT. AND PUT FINANCING
BEHIND IT WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS
IN ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTING IT TO
AND GETTING TO A POINT THAT
THAT WE HAVE UNIVERSAL NIELSEN
MAYBE I'LL START WITH ELLIE
GARNER AND THEN TAKE ANYBODY
ELSE THAT WISHES TO RESPOND. AT
THE HALF THE QUESTION. WELL IT
IS A HAVE GOAL. ASSEMBLY IN. I
THINK THAT I'M I WANT TO YOU
CAN OUT ON OF THE CALL BUT I
THINK THE WE- I'D LIKE TO READ
THAT THE S. P. IN THE APART
ADVENTURE REALLY DO SUPPORT THE-
OF THE DEMOCRATIC IN UNIVERSE
ACCESS TO HEALTHY AND
NUTRITIOUS MEALS BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT ARE UNIVERSAL
MEAL PROGRAM BE FIX FISCALLY
SUSTAINABLE AND THAT WE
MAXIMIZE ALL FEDERAL MEAL
REIMBURSEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
BEFORE SUPPLEMENTING WITH
ADDITIONAL FUNDS SO I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT IN THE
STRUCTURE THAT WE BUILD FOR
THIS PROGRAM. WE ENSURE THAT
WERE ACCESSING AND UTILIZING
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE MAXIMUM
CAPACITY AND SUPPLEMENTING ON A
STATE LEVEL- WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH SENATOR SKINNER ON
THIS BILL BOTH ON A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PLEASE AND AT THE S.
S. P. I. IS SPONSORING THE BILL
SO I WOULD SAY THAT WE ARE IN A
GOOD PLACE- BUT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT REQUIRING ALL SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE FEDERAL
SCHOOL NUTRITION MEAL PROGRAMS
AND AS SENATOR AND SHE'LL TELL
ABOUT WHAT DID MENTION THERE
ARE SOME BARRIERS AND SOME
SCHOOLS HAVE NOT WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM.
BUT REQUIRING THAT
PARTICIPATION WILL ENSURE THAT
WE CAN MAXIMIZE FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT- AND
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE COST
ON TO THE STATE CAN IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU HAVE TO HAVE FOR
YOU GO BECAUSE I THINK IT DID A
GOOD JOB OF ANSWERING THE
QUESTION- LET ME JUST EMPHASIZE
THAT ONE OF THE PIECES OF THIS
IS MAXIMIZING THE FEDERAL
REPAYMENT REIMBURSEMENTS AND
BUILDING OFF THE WAIVERS AND SO
THE QUESTION IS SINCE WE- WANT
TO MAKE THAT A PIECE OF THIS IS
THERE AN IMPLEMENTATION PROBLEM
WITH FACT BECAUSE I THINK YOU
EXPRESSED THE CONCERN THAT WE
ACTUALLY DO IT WHO. IF WE DO
MOVE TO UNIVERSAL WE ARE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT IT THE
STAFF REYES AND IMPLEMENTATION.
PROBLEM WE DON'T FORESEE EMBLEM.
PROBLEM THAT IT WILL HAVE TO BE
A ROCK. ON SCHOOL AND I'M GONNA
DEFERRED A CAMERA THIS BUT-
THERE DC ANY I JUST CASES I'VE
MISSED CAMP NOW I YOU DID IF.
JOB AND WE KNOW THE ISSUE. THE
FOOD TO OF- I WENT JUST KIDDING
I'M JUST KIDDING. I THINK HE IS
A FABULOUS. THANK WELL THE
ENGINE THE FED WAIVER ARE WILL
LOOKS- THE TO DO FEDERAL WAY
FOR SCHOOLS. THE UNIVERSE MEALS
THINKING BACK TO THE WAY.
EXPIRE AND GO THE ANTI SCHOOL
SCHOOL COMING UP SO WE OUR
PROPOSED OF UNITS ME THAT WOULD
START IN- TWENTY TWENTY. IT'S
COMMON ALLY. AND IS ALLEY- TO
THE ONLY ONE MAXIMIZE THE THAT
THE FUND. AND ALSO A LINE
THREE. I MEAN THERE ARE GOOD
HEALTH. AND YOU STANDARDS IN
THE FEDERAL MEAL PROGRAMS
THERE'S- YOU KNOW TRAINING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
REQUIREMENTS AND SO THE BARRIER
THAT I WOULD SEE IT IS JUST IS
JUST LOOKING UP THE PROGRAM AND
YES YOU KNOW WILL NEED SOME
MORE STAFFING WILL HAVE MORE
SCHOOLS COMING ON TO THE
PROGRAM. BUT WE'RE READY AND
REALLY EXCITED TO REALLY LOOK
TO SEE HOW HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS
HAPPEN. GREAT TO KNOW IF WE
ENACTED WE WOULD WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER ON EXACTLY. OF THOSE
THINGS AND I SHOULD ALSO SORT
OF EMPHASIZE THERE'S A PROCESS
NUANCE HERE WE ARE NOT HEARING
THAT BILL BUT IF THAT BILL.
PASSES OR SOMETHING ELSE
HAPPENS- WILL WITH THE FRAME OF
BUDGET TO M. IT SO I THINK THAT
THE AND- TO THING. UP BEFORE
LEAVE THE STOP IS- ANY THING
ANY ELSE TO ADD. TO THEN BY
SAYING NO ONE LET ME THANK OUR
PANELISTS OF THIS WAS A GREAT
DISCUSSION IT WAS REALLY
HELPFUL. AND I THINK PEOPLE
WERE VERY RESPONSIVE TO THE
QUESTIONS IN THE AGENDA AND THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE ASKED BY
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER SEN. LET'S
JUST SAY TAT THE AMOUNT OF
TIME WE SPEND ON THIS IS
DIRECTLY RELATED TO HOW
IMPORTANT WE THINK IT IS AND
HOW WE WILL WANT TO WORK.
TOGETHER ON WHATEVER COMES OUT
OF THE BUDGET TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE GET IT IMPLEMENTED IN A GOOD
WAY SO THANK YOU AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE. AND WE REMOVED
ISSUE NUMBER TWO STATEWIDE
STUDENT ASSESSMENTS WE HAVE
THREE PANELISTS MICHELLE BALL
VALVE DVF FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ONLY GARNERED AGAIN
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND BROOKS ALLEN TO
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION WILL GO IN
THAT ORDER AND WILL BEGIN WITH
MICHELLE FAULTY VIA. HI GOOD
MORNING CHEN MEMBERS- AND SHALL
BE THAT WITH THE DEPARTMENT. SO
AS NOTED IN THE AGENDA
GOVERNOR'S INCLUDES A HUNDRED
EIGHTY MERRILEES. AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND AND NINETEEN POINT
EIGHT MILLION AND FEDERAL TITLE
FOR FUNDS TO COVER COSTS FOR
STATEWIDE STUDENT ASSESSMENT IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO- AND WE
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ENSURE THAT THE AMOUNTS
PROVIDED. ALIGNED WITH THEIR
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO ESTIMATED
STUDENT ASSESSMENT COSTS- AND
IT'S ALWAYS A PLEASURE TO
AMOUNTS WERE BE AFTER. AT THE
REVISION BASED ON CLASS
ESTIMATES- AND WE CAN SPEAK ON
THAT ONCE IN A IS RELEASE- I
BELIEVE HEAR MORE ABOUT WE-
STAY FOR AT. THAT HAVE AFFECT-
STILL TESTING. SO WITH THAT AND
HOW TO ANSWER ANY FROM OF.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE'RE MOVE TO CALI GARNER.
THANK YOU TO. I LIKE HONOR IN
BEHALF OF STATE SUPERINTENDENT
INTO. SUITOR THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY YEAR ALL
CASH AND PACKS ON THE NEXT.
WITH THIS. SOME ALLEY A ALREADY
TO TELL PER. AND SMALL NUMBER
IT ACTUALLY. TESTING THERE'S-
WHEN LEN CLOSED IN MARCH.
TWENTY THE CURRENTLY A FEDERAL
WAY WAS WORK AND AWAY THE
FEDERAL NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
STUDENTS REPORT. GIVEN THE
CHOICE CREATED BY THE PANDEMIC
AND THE- OF DIFFERENT IN.
FORMATS THAT AT LEAST HAVE BEEN
WORK IN THE TWO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SCHOOL YEAR ITWAS THAT IT
FIVE. WAS NEEDED IN PLANNING
FOR THE STATE ESTATE MIGHT
ASSESS FOR THIS TWENTY TWO ONE.
AS OF THIS. THE CD AND THE
STATE OF THAT TAX TO A
SHORTENED VERY OF THE SMARTER
BALANCED SUMMATIVE ASSESSMENTS
FOR ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND
MATHEMATICS AND TO ALLOW FOR
THE OFFERING OF REMOTE
ADMINISTRATION VALUES FOR THE
L. PACK AND CAST ASSESSMENTS.
WITH AN EXCEPTION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENTS FOR E.
LA MATH AND SCIENCE WHICH
RECOMMENDED TO BE ADMINISTERED
IN PERSON FOLLOWING LOCAL
HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDELINES.
ON FEBRUARY TWENTY SECOND. THE
U. S. DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
GUIDANCE OUTLINED FLEXIBILITY
IS MADE AVAILABLE TO SEIZE IN
ORDER TO SATISFY THE FEDERAL
ASSESSMENTS AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF WAIVERS FROM
CERTAIN ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ACADEMIC YEAR AS A RESULT OF
THE PANDEMIC. THE DEPARTMENT AT
THE AT THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ALSO EXPRESSLY STATED
THAT IT WOULD NOT BE INVITING
STATES TO APPLY FOR BLANKET
WAIVERS THAT WOULD ALLOW STATES
TO OPT OUT OF. ANNUAL TESTING
ALTOGETHER. IN THEIR FEBRUARY
AND MARCH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
MEETINGS THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION ACCESS DELIVERY AND
TAKE ACTION THAT WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
LETTER AND TO EXPLORE
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITIES AS
REQUESTED BY STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS. AND I'M GOING TO DEFER
TO MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION TO SHARE THE
DETAILS OF THE OF THE BOARD
APPROVED ASSESSMENT POLICY. BUT
WITH ME TODAY IS MALABANG CD IS
DIRECTOR OF ASSESSMENT
DEVELOPMENT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
DIVISION THE ANSWER ANY
PROGRAMMATIC QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ON THE CHANGES THAT
CDP HAS AND LAMENTED IN THE
LAST YEAR. AND FOR THE CHANGES
THAT ARE GOING FORWARD IN THE
FALL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NOW WE MOVE TO. OF BROOKS
ALLEN OF THE STATE BOARD OF.
EDUCATION WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU JEREMY. OF
OUR EXECUTIVE. OF THIS MORE
THAN. OR THE PAST YEAR THE
STATE OF EDUCATION'S WORK. WITH
THE EDUCATION. TEACHERS ADMIT.
AND PARENTS TO ORGANISE A- TO
ESTABLISH A SAYS POLICY AND
PRACTICE THERE'S TWO. FOCUS
ANDERSON. TO THE FACTS OF CODE
NINETEEN AND THE PANDEMIC HOW
THAT IS COMPLETE. REDEFINED
LIFE FOR STUDENTS FAMILIES.
EDUCATORS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
AT THIS CRITICAL JUNCTURE OF
THE BOARDING DEPARTMENT AND
REMAIN FOCUSED ON DRESSING
VARIED AND OFTEN VERY URGENT
NEEDS. OF THE MORE THAN SIX
MILLION STUDENTS WHO ATTEND ARE
MORE THAN TEN THOUSAND.
ALLOCATE ALL SCHOOLS. AS WE ALL
KNOW VALID RELIABLE AND
MEANINGFUL DATA ON STUDENT
LEARNING CAN HELP DIRECT STATE
AND FEDERAL FUNDING AND
RESOURCES THAT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED THROUGH ASSEMBLY
BUYING SEX. WHICH I THROUGH
YOUR LEADERSHIP IS NOW REALITY
FOR STATE. OF THE CARE IS ACT
ARC FUNDING- COME FROM FEDERAL.
TO THOSE RESOURCES TO WEAR
THEIR NEW MOST AND TO THAT END.
SINCE THE BEGINNING A PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIA STRATEGIZE DEVELOP
ASSESSMENT PLAN WOULD. DATA TO
PARA AND YOU AND PUBLIC.
REGARDING THE PROGRESS OF
STUDENTS. INCLUDING THE
PROVISION OF IN TERMS SAYS%
MEANT TOOLS- THAT MS GARNER
REFERRED TO. OF THE TITLE IS
MORE ABOUT SUCCESS CONSORTIUM
AND THE USE OF OTHER.
NATIONALLY BELL I CAN. TESTS
THEIR LINES ARE STAGED. THREE
WOMEN ON A MEMBERS. OF THE YEAR
STATE BOARD OF ED. APPROVED THE
USE IT JUST BLUEPRINT. WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE USE OF SHORT
TIME FORM IN LANGUAGE ARE AND
MATH SOME OF HIS. NOTABLY THIS
ADJUSTED. RESPONSE I TO REALLY
THE CAN THAT WE SEE ACROSS THE
STATE I REDUCING THIS. TIME
PREACHED BY ABOUT ONE OF HOURS.
STRAINERS PARENTS AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS. DISCUSSING
CRITICALLY CHALLENGING
CONDITIONS FACING OUR TEACHERS.
ADMINISTRATORS STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES. AFTER MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT SESSIONS
DISCUSSION OF FLEXIBILITY AS
THEY CAN A COMPANY STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENTS. AND MULTIPLE
ROUNDS OF EXTENSIVE WRITTEN AND
ORAL COMMENTS FROM
STAKEHOLDERS. STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION APPROVED AN EXTENSION
OF OUR TESTING WINDOW THIS YEAR
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE YEAR
FOR ALL LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES. THROUGH JULY THIRTY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
ALL STATE SUMMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS. AND OFTEN
ASSESSMENT POLICY FOR THIS YEAR
THAT INCLUDES UNIVERSAL.
COMPATIBILITY OF OUR STATEWIDE
ASSESSMENTS. AND IMPORTANTLY IS
RESPONSIVE TO THE CONDITIONS WE
STILL SEE ACROSS OUR STATE.
CONTINUES TO PROVIDE THE
SMARTER BALANCED SUMMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS AND CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE ASSESSMENTS C. A.
R. FOR EXAM WAS ARTS AND
MATHEMATICS AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA SCIENCE TEST. AND
THE CA FOR SCIENCE AND THE SOME
OF THE VALPAK OF FOR ALL LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
IMPORTANTLY TO PROVIDE QUALITY
DATA REGARDING STUDENT LEARNING
AND PROGRESS TO PARENTS
EDUCATORS AND THE PUBLIC WERE
CIRCUMSTANCES DO NOT MAKE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STATE
SOME OF THE STUFF SINCE VIABLE.
WITHIN THE LOCAL CONTEXT THE
STATE MORTGAGE CREATION
APPROVED THE USE OF OTHER
ASSESSMENTS THAT ALIGN WITH
CALIFORNIA'S STANDARDS AND
PROVIDE RESULTS THAT CAN BE
REPORTED TO PARENTS AND
GUARDIANS. AND EDUCATORS AND
THE PUBLIC. I JUST LIKE INSIDE
AGAIN AT THE SUMMIT AVAIL
PACKED BRINGS LEARNERS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE ADMINISTERED TO
ALL IN RESPONSE. ACCORDINGLY
ACROSS OUR STATE WHERE IS THE
MOST VIABLE OPTION WE EXPECT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES WILL
CONTINUE TO ADMINISTER THE
STATE WANTS SOME OF THE
SUSPECTS. AND WE'RE STATEWIDE
SOME ASSESSMENT IS NOT. THE
MOST VIABLE OPTION FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY OR FOR ONE
MORE THE GREAT LEVELS WITH THE
END. OF THAT DISTRICT OR
CHARTER SCHOOL. I ALWAYS ME
REPORT RESULTS FROM A DIFFERENT
ASSESSMENT MEETS THE CRITERIA
ESTABLISHED BY THE STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION ON MARCH
SIXTEENTH. I PERSONALLY AND AS
NOTED IN YOUR AGENDA MATERIALS
THESE ASSESSMENTS MUST BE
ALIGNED WITH CALIFORNIA COMES
COURSE STATE STANDARDS FOR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATH.
YOU MUST BE AVAILABLE THIS IS
STUDENTS IN GRADES. THREE
THROUGH EIGHT AND GRADE. AND
THEY MUST BE UNIFORMLY
ADMINISTERED ACROSS THE GREAT
EXPANSE SCHOOL DISTRICT. AND
FINALLY THEY MUST PROVIDE
RESULTS CAN BE REPORTED TO
PARENTS AND GUARDIANS EDUCATORS
ABOUT INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS. AND
TO THE PUBLIC BY SCHOOL IN MY
DISTRICT. AND MUST. BE ABLE TO
BE DISAGGREGATED BY STUDENT
GROUPS. OUR A BE HAPPY NOW ANY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS TO ALL THREE
PANELISTS AND I'M GONNA BEGIN.
WITH QUESTIONS AND MAYBE WE'LL
STICK WITH MR ALLEN AND DON'T
LET OTHER PEOPLE. RESPOND BUT
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND. OF FIVE READ.
BASICALLY A SUMMARY OF WHAT YOU
JUST SAID ANYWAY. AND I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW IT
FITS TIME WISE- WHAT THE FLIES
THAT YOU'VE ALREADY DECIDED TO
THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR. IN AND IF
IT DOES THAT MEAN THAT WHAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED APPLIES
COMPLETELY THE NEXT SCHOOL YEAR
WILL YOU BE REVISITING IT AT
SOME POINT TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT. YOU UPDATED PARTICULARLY
IF STUDENTS ARE COMING BACK. IN
OVERWHELMING NUMBERS FOR IN
PERSON EDUCATION. YEAH RIGHT
NOW ALL OF THE DECISIONS THAT I
JUST OUTLINED APPLY TO THIS
CURRENT SCHOOL YEAR THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR AND FAR
SPRINGS ABSENT WINDOW. REALLY
NOTABLY BY EXTENDING THE
TESTING WINDOW TO THE END OF
JULY THAT'S REALLY THE MOST
APPLICABLE LONGER TERM
DECISIONS BEEN MADE AT THIS
POINT OTHERWISE ALL DECISIONS
ARE APPLICABLE JUST TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SCHOOL YEAR
AND THAT TO YOUR POINT WILL BE
REVISITED FOR NEXT YEAR
DEPENDING ON THE CONDITIONS WE
FACE. OKAY AND THEN ARE PREVENT
ME ASKED THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- MICHELLE EVEN THOUGH I
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
ALREADY. I ASSUME THAT THAT THE
MAY REVISE WILL ADDRESS THIS IN
SOME WAY BUT TO TURN NOT.
PREPARED TO TALK ABOUT OR DID
ANYONE. YEAH I THINK- I THINK
YESTERDAY EXACTLY- WE ARE
LOOKING AT- REVISIONS YOU KNOW
FOR THE MAY REVISED BUT WE
CAN'T REALLY SPEAK. AT THIS
TIME. OKAY BECAUSE IT. IT EVEN
THOUGH I APPRECIATE THAT THAT
WOULD REALLY HELP US OUT-
TRYING TO CONTEMPLATE NEXT YEAR
THE N. N. A. N. IT IS ALWAYS A
BIT OF A CHICKEN AND THE EGG
BECAUSE THE STATE ALL. OF OUR
BOARD OF EDUCATION HAS TO DO
WHAT THEY REQUIRE IN THE BUDGET
HAS TO FOLLOW AND- EVERY SO
OFTEN THE BUDGET LEADS AND-
STATE BOARD FOLLOWS AND SO I
THINK THAT'S JUST WHERE. ARE
YOU WE WILL HAVE AN INTEREST
AND OBVIOUSLY BY THE TIME WE
MAKE A DECISION ON THIS THE MAY
REVISE WILL BE AND THEN AND WE
WILL REFLECT ON. ON WHATEVER'S.
IN IT TO DO WHAT. I WAS GOING
TO ASK ANOTHER QUESTION-
BECAUSE IT WAS JUST DISCUSS.
WITH THE STATE BOARD. WHAT
HAPPENS THE WORK HAS HAPPENED
FOR THE SPRING. AND FALL ARE
THEY'RE EXPECTED TO BE
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS OVER WHAT
WAS BUDGETED FOR THE FISCAL
YEAR BASED ON THE DECISIONS
THAT WERE JUST. MADE FOR WHAT
HAPPENS IN THE SPRING. AND I
THINK FINDING A JUST WITH THE
WHICH- ASSEMBLY GET IN WITH A
PERMANENT FINANCE AND WE DO
PLAN TO ACCOUNT FOR SAVINGS
FROM- SPRING OF TWENTY TWENTY
SO THIS CURRENT- TESTING CYCLE
AS PART OF THE NEW REVISED AND
AGAIN- ABLE TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ONCE THAT HAS BEEN
RELEASED- YEAH THAT'S REALLY
ALL WE CAN SAY AT THIS TIME.
OKAY BUT- THAT DID POINT US IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION WHILE STILL
OFFICIALLY. AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FEELS
BEING CRYPTIC SO FAR. YES L. A.
GARNER ON THE OTHER THE
SUPERINTENDENT IF I MAY ASK I
WOULD AGREE THAT IT'S TOO
EARLY- AT THIS POINT IN TIME TO
BE ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT THAT'S
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT SAVING
MIGHT BE IT'S ALSO- TOO EARLY
TO CONFIRM THE NUMBER OF TEST
TAKERS IN THE SPRING OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE CAST
GIVEN THE EXTENSION OF THE
STATEWIDE TESTING WINDOW. SO
THAT IS ANOTHER- VARIABLE THAT
HAS TO BE CONSIDERED IN
IDENTIFYING THE SAVINGS THAT
MIGHT BE ACTUALLY A PART OF THE
PROCESS AND ALSO FOR THE L.
PACK ALL ENGLISH LEARNERS ARE
REQUIRED TO BE TESTED AND IT IS
NOT BAD AT THAT THERE WILL BE
ANY SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS FROM
THE OUTBACK. AND JUST EIGHTY
VENDO- THIS WAS SPOKEN TO IN A
WIFE WANTED TO JUST CONTINUE
OUR COMMENTS AND SAY WHY.
CERTAINLY SO- WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE TO
IDENTIFY POTENTIAL SAVINGS BOTH
FROM THE SPRING ADMINISTRATION
OF TWENTY TWENTY AND THIS IS A
AND THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
THE TESTING WAS POSITIVE IN
EARLY EARLY MARCH BUT THE
PROCESS STILL CONTINUES ON. HOW
TO UPDATE THOSE EXAMS AND
PROVIDE THEM IN A VIRTUAL
ENVIRONMENT. AND BOB CONTINUE
FOR US TO FIND WAYS TO MAKE
THOSE AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
AND- THE SAVINGS IS NOT AS
SIGNIFICANT AS ONE MIGHT
ANTICIPATE. OKAY THANK YOU-
THIS WOULD BE THE TIME FOR ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MANY MEMBERS-
CENTER ULTRABOOK ANY QUESTIONS.
FOR A CENTER BERMAN YEAH- THANK
YOU- I GUESS MY QUESTION IS
THERE ARE SOME IN THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT FEEL
LIKE. ASSESSMENTS HAVE LIMITED
VALUE- WE KIND OF HAD A MASS
EXPERIMENT- IN REDUCING THE
SCALE AND SCOPE OF THESE
ASSESSMENTS. I DO WE HAVE ANY
DATA ACK YET THAT MIGHT
SUGGEST- WHETHER THESE ARE AS
EFFECTIVE AS THE TRADITIONAL
ASSESSMENTS- WITH A FEWER HOURS
PER STUDENT VIEW ACROSS THE
STATE. I'M SORRY SENATOR CAN BE
CUTE X. EXPLAINED THE QUESTION
A LITTLE BIT MORE YEAH AND THIS
MIGHT ACTUALLY BE FASTER MR
ALLEN BUT- YOU KNOW WE
BASICALLY HAD YOU KNOW A YEAR
WHERE WE'VE BEEN RELY AND I
REALIZE THAT THE DATA IS NOT
ALL IN BECAUSE HE'S JUST
MENTIONED. NOT ALL STUDENTS
HAVE TAKEN THE TEST THE TESTING
WINDOW STILL OPEN BUT I DO WE
HAVE ANY SENSE OF WHETHER THE
REDUCE TESTING IS AS EFFECTIVE
IN ASSESSING STUDENTS. ARE ES
THE TRADITIONAL ASSESSMENTS.
BEFORE I DEFER TO MY COLLEAGUE
AT THE STATE BOARD WE DON'T
HAVE THAT DATA YET- TO BE ABLE
TO ANSWER THAT THE SHORTENED
FORM THAT WAS. ADOPTED WE DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION AND SO.
WE CAN DO COMPARISON ONCE WE
HAVE THE DATA BUT AGAIN BECAUSE
THE WINDOW IS EXTENDED AND WE
HAVE A LONGER TIME PERIOD WE'RE
GOING TO BE. A LITTLE BIT
BEHIND ON BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
ANY DATA WE WILL BE CONDUCTING
ANALYSIS BUT ARE JUST NOT READY
TO ANSWER AT THIS POINT IN TIME.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND- I GUESS
THE- BROADER POINT IS IF THIS
IS. SOMETHING THAT WE DO SEE IS
AN EFFECTIVE PROXY IS THERE
SOME POSSIBILITY TO. YOU KNOW.
MAKE THIS A PERMANENT CHANGE AS
OPPOSED TO JUST A TEMPORARY
COVERT NINETEEN DRIVEN. CHANGE
CITY CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING YOU THAT ANALYSIS
ONCE WE HAVE THE DATA DATA
BACK- I WOULD DEFER TO THE- TO
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
ON NEXT STEPS AS FAR AS
CHANGING ASSESSMENT. THANK YOU.
NONE MISTER ALAN ANYTHING TO
ADD ON. YES SAID I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THIS IS EXACTLY THE
QUESTION THAT CAME UP BEFORE
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
AND THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONTEMPLATE WHEN THERE WAS THE
MOVE MADE TO THE SHORT FORM
ASSESSMENTS IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
ARTS AND MATH WHICH I BELIEVE
IS WHERE QUESTIONS FOCUSED- YOU
CAN MAKE THAT WILL LOOK IF WE
CAN DO IT LAST TIME RIGHT LIKE
TAT THAT SEEMS TO BE A GOOD
THING BECAUSE WE KNOW ONE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT COMES UP IS
THE MOUNTAIN STRUCTURAL TIMES
TAKEN PROCESS AND- I WILL
BEFORE I THINK OF BOTH IS GONNA
HAVE OF COLLEAGUES WHO ARE MUCH
DEEPER- INTO PSYCHOMETRIC PARTS
OF THE OF THE ASSESSMENTS TO BE
ABLE TO DISCUSS. THERE ARE
CERTAIN LIMITATIONS IN TERMS OF
MOBILITY AROUND THE CLAIMS THAT
CAN BE MADE AND AT WHAT LEVEL-
ONCE YOU GO TO A SHORTENED FORM
ASSESSMENT. OR AN INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS ARE VERSUS WHAT CAN BE
DONE- OBVIOUSLY ACROSS MORE
AGGREGATE LEVEL AND SO YOU DO
LOSE A LITTLE BIT OF THAT- BUT
TO THE DETAIL OF THAT- I'M LIKE
A BIRD I THERE'S A COUPLE ARE
CALLING SO I KNOW ARE ARE
AVAILABLE NOW OR ABILITY. TO
REPORT BACK AS MISS BERNARD
SUGGESTED. I DON'T SEE ANYBODY
ELSE- BRUSHING TO COMMENT HOW
DOES THAT COMPLETE YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR THEN LET ME
THANK YOU ALL- ON PANEL TWO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
ARE WAITING WITH BATED BREATH
FOR THE MAY REVISE AND THEN WE
WILL DECIDE WHERE WE GO- BUT
WE- APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH
US TODAY. SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO ISSUE THREE STATE
OPERATIONS. APOLLO FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EMILY
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND NOW WE GARNER FROM
THE- DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU
CHAIR GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HEALTH
MINISTER TANG WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'LL
KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF AND
PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION STATE
OPERATIONS BUDGET. HUNDREDS
BUDGET PROVIDES APPROXIMATELY
FOUR HUNDRED TEN MILLION IN
STATE OPERATIONS SUPPORT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. WE A
TOTAL OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO
MILLION IS PROVIDED TO SUPPORT
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED AND TEN AUTHORIZED
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HEADQUARTERS. THIS IS
NOT FOR THE HEADQUARTERS
CONSISTS OF EIGHTY MILLION NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO MILLION FEDERAL FUNDS AND
FORTY MILLION OTHER FANS.
ADDITIONALLY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION SUPPORTS APPROXIMATELY
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY POSITIONS
AT THE STATE SPECIAL SCHOOLS.
THIS AMOUNT CONSISTS OF SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL PLAN WHAT
SIXTY ONE MILLION DOLLAR
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
AND ONE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
OTHER FAT. I'M NOW MOVE ON TO
THE BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS AS
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES. ONE
MILLION ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS
FOR A ONE YEAR EXTENSION OF THE
SACKS ENTERED ICE CODE
STRUCTURE REPLACEMENT PROJECTS.
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDS TO
SUPPORT PROJECT CAL STOP WHICH
STANDS FOR STUDENTS TEACHERS
AND OFFICERS PREVENTING
VIOLENCE. ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND ONGOING
FEDERAL FUNDS AND ONE POSITION
TO FULFILL NEW DATA COLLECTION
AND REPORTING REQUIREMENTS%
RELATED TO THE FEDERAL EVERY
STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT. THE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
I'M NOT ON THE AGENDA NOTES THE
ORIGINAL REQUEST. NEXT TWELVE
POINT SIX MILLION ONGOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO BANKROLL CHILD
CARE NUTRITION PROGRAMS
POSITIONS SHIFTING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THERE'S ALSO TWO HUNDRED SIX
THOUSAND ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
ACTIVITIES CONSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION. AND FINALLY
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
ONGOING NOT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND. POSITION TO
SUPPORT THE SCHOOL EMERGENCY
REPORTING SYSTEM. THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
MOVE TO THE LA L. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AMY LEE WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS ON THE
CITY-STATE'S OPERATIONS REQUEST
CAN BE FOUND UNDER ISSUE THREE
OF TODAY'S AGENDA. AS YOU CAN
SEE IN THE TABLE AND THE AGENDA
WE BELIEVE MOST OF THE REQUESTS
ARE REASONABLE AND WOULD HELP
CD EVEN MEET NEW AND EXISTING
RESPONSIBILITIES. WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
SEAT REQUEST WITH THE ONE
EXCEPTION BEING THE REQUEST TO
BACK FILL EIGHTY THREE
POSITIONS THAT ARE SHIFTING TO
DSS AS PART OF THAT TRANSITION
APPROVED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET. THIS REQUEST WOULD
ALLOW SEAT TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THE STATE PRESCHOOL
AND CHILD NUTRITION PROGRAMS
REMAINING AT CITY AFTER
TRANSITIONING TO THE CHILD CARE
PROGRAM CDSS. HOWEVER BECAUSE
STAFFING LEVELS WILL BE
DEPENDENT ON OTHER DECISIONS WE
RECOMMEND CONFORMING STAFFING
LEVELS AFTER THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE OTHER DECISIONS
RELATED TO THE TRANSITION. I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
AND THEN REMOVED EARLY GUARD.
THANK HONOR ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION I WOULD START WITH
THE THANK YOU'S THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
COLLABORATION AS WE HAVE WORKED
YOUR SEATS RESOURCE NEEDS WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THAT
WORK ON OUTSTANDING ITEMS AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE TO THE BUDGET
PROCESS. I WILL MANY OF CD'S
BCPS AND THE OPERATIONS
REQUESTS ARE IN LINE WITH-
TYPICALLY COME BEFORE YOU AND
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
MAJOR PIECE AND THE CDC
OPERATIONS REQUEST INVOLVES
ENSURING CDP HAS ENOUGH STAFF
THE CAN YOU CONTINUE OPERATING
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM. AND THE SCHOOL CHILD
MCNEIL PROGRAMS AFTER THE
TRANSITION OF THE OF CHILD CARE
AND CHILD ADULT CARE FOOD
PROGRAM TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ON JULY THE FIRST. OVER THE
LAST YEAR'S THE EASEMENT
COORDINATING WITH CDSS
DETERMINE HOW TO SUCCESSFULLY
IMPLEMENT THE TRANSITION WHILE
MINIMIZING DISRUPTION TO
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES ONCE THE
TRANSITION IS IMPLEMENTED CD
WILL NEED SIGNIFICANT STAFF
RESOURCES TO CONTINUE THE
CURRENT EVEN MODIFIED SUPPORTS
THE COUNTRY CONTRACTORS AS WELL
AS THIRTEEN STAFF AND OUR
NUTRITION SERVICES DIVISION
ONCE WE NO LONGER HAVE ACCESS
TO SOME OF THE FEDERAL STATE
ADMINISTRATION FUNDS. WHILE
MANY PROGRAMS WILL BE
TRANSITIONING TRANSPACIFIC
WHILE MANY PROGRAMS WILL BE
TRANSITIONING TO CDSS ALONG
WITH OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY
STAFF AND RELATED FUNDING. WE
WOULDN'T CALL THIS A LIFT AND
SHIFT AS A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
OF WORK WILL STILL REMAIN AT
CD. CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
AND ALL OF THE CHILD MEAL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS PREVIOUSLY
HAVE BEEN ADMINISTERED
CONCURRENTLY WITH STAFF WORKING
ACROSS PROGRAM TYPES TO MONITOR
AND PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE THE CITY IS NOT
FUNDED ON A PER PROGRAM BASIS
BUT INSTEAD LEVERAGES STAFFING
ACROSS MULTIPLE PROGRAMS FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE AND STATE
OPERATIONS EFFICIENCIES. AFTER
THE TRANSITIONS MANY FUNCTIONS
WILL BE DUPLICATED AT BOTH
DEPARTMENTS AND CD ONE THE
RESOURCES TO REPLACE SOME OF
THE FUNDING BEING THAT THE
CDSS. WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
CD IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET CD
CONTINUES TO WORK CLOSELY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
ENSURE THAT SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES ARE PROVIDED SENATE
SEAT CAN CONTINUE THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN. AND THAT IS
REQUIRED TO DO FOR THE
REMAINING PRESCHOOL IN THE-
PROGRAM THAT LEARNING AT SEA. I
AND MY COLLEAGUES ARE NOT
MORGAN LEAST IN THE HERE TO
ANSWER SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
THREE. REGARDING BCPS AND THE
UPCOMING TRANSITIONS. OF CITIES
PROGRAMS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THAT COMPLETES
THE- THE PANEL PRESENTATIONS
AND EVERYBODY SEEMED TO-
ADDRESSED THE SUGGESTED
QUESTIONS ON THE AGENDA BUT-
LET ME JUST ASK ONE VOTE
CABALLERO. COMMENTED ON. AN
ISSUE WITH THE BACKFILL OF
EIGHTY POSITIONS AND I WONDERED
IF. EITHER FINANCE OR CD HE
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND TO THAT.
LISTENING OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I CAN START OFF SO THE
FACTUAL  JUST WANT TO CLARIFY-
OF THE EIGHTY THREE POSITIONS
FIFTY THREE OUR EXISTING
POSITIONS AT THE DEPARTMENT. OF
EDUCATION- THESE THESE ARE
POSITIONS THAT I WILL NO LONGER
BE FUNDED DUE TO THE SHIFT OF
THE CHILD AND ADULT CARE FOOD
PROGRAM OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES- DEPARTMENT
HAS BEEN ABLE TO DRAW DOWN
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS- FOR THE
CCF PETER SQUARE OTHER
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. AND NOW
THAT THE CA CFP IS SHIFTING
THEY NO LONGER HAVE ACCESS TO
THOSE ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDS SO-
YOU KNOW THESE ARE FOR. YOUR
POSITIONS ARE SUPPORTING OTHER
NUTRITION PROGRAMS THAT ARE
STAYING AT CD. SELL A BOOK
FUNDING IS TO BACK FILLING
THOSE FIFTY THREE EXISTING
POSITIONS THAT ARE- STAYING AT
THE DEPARTMENT. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
YOUR COMMENT A ET IS IT THAT.
THE PROGRAM SHIFTING AWAY AND
THE MONEY IS SHIFTING AWAY BUT
YOU BELIEVE THERE ARE STILL
DUTIES THAT REMAIN THERE AND
THEREFORE YOU HAVE TO BACK FILL
SOME OF THE POSITIONS TO
CONTINUE THE DUTIES THE STAFF
WHAT DOES THIS IS A FAIR
SUMMARY OF WHAT YOU JUST SAID.
RIGHT THE CA CFP PROGRAM IS
SHIFTING TO DS US BUT THESE
POSITIONS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
FUNDED WITH C. A. C. F. P.
ADMINISTRATIVE DOLLARS ARE
SUPPORTING OTHER PROGRAM THAT
SEATS ARE UNRELATED. THE
PROGRAM THAT ARE- THAT WOULD NO
LONGER BE FUNDED. YOU SORT OF
SAID RIGHT AND THEN YOU MADE A
COMMENT AFTER THAT THAT DIDN'T
SOUND LIKE IT MATCHED SO UP-
LET ME JUST NOT DWELL ON THIS
TOO MUCH BUT LET ME ASK AMY LEE
pTHAT BEFORE WE MOVE ON AND I
SEE EDGAR CAME ON AND I DON'T
KNOW IF. THE IF HE WISHES TO
RESPOND BUT- WILL LET YOU GUYS
CHOOSE PUT A ONE OF YOU
RESPOND. THE SENATOR IF I COULD
ASK MY COLLEAGUES AT THE ALLEY
EITHER ANCHOR CABRAL- SECRET
HAS ACTUALLY WE AND I MISSED
ONE THANK GOD THERE WAS JUMPING
IN SO HERE WE GO- GOOD MORNING.
EVER DOUBLE THE- ANALYST'S
OFFICE BIG IN INCOME THE BIG
BRIDGE RETURN. SOME OF THE
COMMENTS WE HAD A MAJOR COULD
YOU YEAR AND A- SOMEONE. THREE
THE CHILD CARE. I THINK WE HAVE
SOME KIND. WITH THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING- AND- BUT THERE WERE
SOME. FUNDING HIS MESSAGE IN
THE- FROM. BEFORE APPROVING THE
PER THIS IN REALLY GETTING
ACTORS. FROM YOUR- OUR- EXACTLY
WHAT THE TRAVIS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE A MORE POSITIONS WERE
NEEDED THE- REMOTE ORIGINAL
COME. EVERY OTHERS OPERATION
HELLO WE DON'T HAVE DISAGREE.
FOLLOW ME BECAUSE PARTY'S PRIOR
CONVERSELY. EVEN THE GOVERNOR'S.
THERE WILL IN APRIL. MATTER FOR
ADDITIONAL. FUNDING FOR DEFENSE
FOR THE CHILD TO THE SERVICES
THAT ARE WE THINK THE
ADDITIONAL. INFORMATION HERE
AND COVERAGE. BEFORE WE FOR WE
WERE OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE- YOUR COMMENTS. IF
I. YES FOR THERE AND EVELYN
MORGAN WHO IS OUR W. DIFFERENT.
ABOUT FOR ALL GRANT TO OVERSEAS
THE BUT THE EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE TRANSITION. EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
THE NUTRITION PROGRAMS. AND HAS
SOME INSIGHT ABOUT SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU JUST HAD
ABOUT THOSE TRANSITIONING
POSITION THAN POLICE. DELIVER
US THAT INSIDE. THANK YOU VERY
MARK FOR THIS SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION. JUST WANTED
TO GO BACK TO WEBER. SAID WHEN.
RESPONDING TO IN. U. S. GET
THIS. OPERATING THAT CHILD
NUTRITION PROGRAMS. THE OF. TO
USE AND- FUNDS. ALL OF MEAL
PROGRAM. TO CREATE A FASHION.
AND HOW YOU. AND OFFER THEM.
AND CHECK ASSISTANCE. SO THEY
NOT ONLY ALLOW FOR THE
ENCOURAGE STATE TO G. THE C. C.
F. P. PARK HAS THE HIGHER.
ADMIN REIMBURSEMENT COMPARED TO
THE OTHER CHILD NUTRITION
PROGRAMS THE CDC HAS USED ALL
OF THOSE NEW PROGRAMS TOGETHER
TO CREATE A STAFFING MONITORING
STRUCTURE WHERE OUR TEAM GOES
OUT AND DAY MONITORING PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. ACROSS
ALL OF THOSE MEAL PROGRAMS THE
A. C. F. P. AS WELL AS THE REST
OF THE SCHOOL MEAL ONCE THE
ONCE THE C. A. C. F. P. IS
REMOVED AND TRANSITIONED OVER
TO DSS. AT THE END LEAVE CD
WITHOUT THE ABILITY TO USE SOME
OF THE STATE ADMINISTRATOR
FUNDS FROM USDA TO HELP OPERATE
THE REST OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
GET A SIGNIFICANTLY SMALLER
ADMINISTRATIVE. STATE
OPERATIONAL RIGHT AND SO THAT'S
THE ONE THAT'S REALLY
SIGNIFICANT YOU ARE SCHOOL
CHILD MEAL PROGRAMS AND HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THOSE.
GOING BACK TO PANEL LINE IN
THAT CONVERSATION AROUND
UNIVERSAL MEALS SO ALL OF THE
WORK OUR TEAM AT CVS I THINK
YOU I THINK YOU MADE THE POINT
REALLY CLEARLY AND I MADE THE
MISTAKE OF JUMPING DOWN THE
RABBIT HOLE. SO WE JUST
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR COMMENTS I
SEE OUR STAFF HAS BEEN
CAREFULLY TAKING NOTES AND WE
WILL JUST WORK ON THIS BEFORE
IT GETS TO US FOR DECISION. ARE
THERE ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
FROM EITHER SENATOR. MEN OR
CENTER OF TROUBLE. SEEING NONE
LET ME THE- WE REALLY. YOU
BEING TODAY. AND WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE LAST ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR EDUCATION FUNDING UNDER
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN. AND
WE'RE BACK TO AMY LEE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND THERE'S AN OUTSIDE CHANCE.
WE WILL HAVE A QUESTION FOR
FINANCE ON THIS SO WE HOPE THAT
EIGHT. DAY STAY WITH US- SO
MISLI. THANK YOU SENATOR. AWARE
SO THIS MORNING I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
EDUCATION FUNDS PROVIDED IN THE
AMERICAN RESCUE PLANNED AIR P.
THIS WAS THE THIRD FEDERAL
RELIEF PACKAGE FOR COPING
NINETEEN. ON THE TABLE UNDER
ISSUE FOR OF THE GENDER DOES A
PRETTY GOOD JOB PLAYING OUT THE
EDUCATION FUNDING THAT WAS
PROVIDED THROUGH THE FEDERAL
LEAVE RELIEF PACKAGES TO DATE.
AS YOU CAN SEE AN AARP COLUMN
OF THE TABLE THE BULK OF THE
AIR P. EDUCATION FINDS WAS
PROVIDED THROUGH A THIRD ROUND
ASRC SHOULD ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY SCHOOL EMERGENCY
RELIEF FUND. CALIFORNIA WILL
RECEIVE ABOUT FIFTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN AFTER THREE FUNDS
THIS IS MORE THAN WICE THE
AMOUNT PROVIDED UNDER THE
SECOND RELIEF PACKAGE FOR CHRIS
AT. OF THE SIGNS 90% OR
THIRTEEN POINT SIX MILLION WILL
BE PROVIDED DIRECTLY TO SCHOOLS
AS GRANTS AND 10% ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION IT WILL BE MADE
AVAILABLE AS SEEK FLEXIBLE
FINES. NOW IN CONTRAST TO THE
PAST TO RELIEF PACKAGES THE
STATE FLEXIBLE FUNDS IN A. R.
P. ARE SUBJECT TO CERTAIN
SPENDING REQUIREMENTS.
SPECIFICALLY THE STATE WILL
HAVE TO SPEND 5% OF ITS TOTAL
ALLOCATION I'M LEARNING
RECOVERY 1% ON SUMMER SCHOOL
AND 1% ON COMPREHENSIVE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS. US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION IS REQUIRING THAT
THE STATE TO MAKE A STATE PLAN
FOR THE USE OF THE STATE
FLEXIBLE FINDS. SOME COMPONENTS
OF THE PLAN INCLUDE THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES FOR THE SIGNS
INCLUDING THOSE FOR UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS ACTIONS TO SUPPORT THE
SCHOOL REOPENING. PLANS TO SEEK
MEANINGFUL STAKEHOLDER INPUT
AND EVIDENCE BASED STRATEGIES
TO SUPPORT THE USE OF THE
RESERVES SET ASIDE FUNDS. NOW
IN LATE APRIL THIS STATE
RECEIVED ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF
ITS S. R. L. THREE ALLOCATION.
THE REMAINING FUNDS WILL BE
MADE AVAILABLE ONCE THE U. S.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
APPROVED CALIFORNIA STATE PLAN.
ONCE THE FUNDS HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED THE STATE HAS ONE YEAR
TO AWARD THE FINDING ANY TILL
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TO EXPAND THE
FINES. COMBINING A VALUABLE
FEDERAL FRIENDS WITH SECOND
FEDERAL RELIEF PACKAGE AND TO
THESE MASSIVE THREE FUNDS. THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE IN TOTAL.
YOU THREE BILLION AVAIL. WANT
AND STATE FOX FUNDS FOR
EDUCATION TO ALLOCATE AND THE
YEAR. NOW IN ADDITION ANSWER
THREE FUNDS HEALTH ALSO. A AND
YOU FROM FROM A. R. P. AS
DESCRIBED IN THE LAST PARAGRAPH
AND I JOINED USAND THIS
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED AND TWO
MILLION ONE TIME AUGMENTATION
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDS.
UNDER THE ID EIGHT ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY EIGHTY ONE MILLION
IN EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE TO
PRIVATE SCHOOLS ROLLING
SIGNIFICANT SHARES OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. AND NINETY
NINE MILLION TO SUPPORT
HOMELESS STUDENTS. AT THIS
POINT WE'RE STILL WAITING ON
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDS AND
HOMELESS STUDENT FINDS. AND THE
LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION IS
JUST. NOT AS A CONDITION OF
FUNDING CALIFORNIA IS REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN FINANCIAL SUPPORT
FOR K. TWELVE EDUCATION AND
HIGHER EDUCATION. IN THE FISCAL
YEAR AS OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE THAT
ARE COMPARABLE TO THE PAST
THREE FISCAL YEARS. M. A. R. P.
ALSO LIMITS- FUNDING REDUCTIONS
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS WITH THE MOST LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. I THINK THAT
HELPED CONCLUDE MY TESTIMONY
BUT HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
N. R. I HAVE ONE GLOBAL
QUESTION AND THIS IS OUR WILL
START WITH YOU AND THIS IS IN
CASE THERE'S SOMEBODY FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT
WISHES TO ADD. AND
UNFORTUNATELY AND THIS IS NOT
YOUR DOING OF THESE PROGRAMS
PRESENT US WITH AN INCREDIBLE
MIX OF ALPHABET SOUP. IT TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND THE ACRONYMS FOR
EVERY SINGLE ONE AND- AND FOR
ME IT'S JUST SORT OF LIKE THE-
THE FIRST EMAIL US THE ONE
ABOUT JANUARY FIRST IN THE
LATEST ONE IS THE WAY TO BEST.
SORT OF UNDERSTAND THEM. N. IN
THE STIMULUS THAT THAT WAS THE
SECOND ONE THAT SEEMS TO BE
REFLECTED. ON THE OVERVIEW
CHART OF C. R. R. S. EIGHT
EIGHT ASTERIX. BOMB HE WE ASKED
ABOUT THIS DURING THE SCHOOL RE
OPENING. BECAUSE WE WERE
CONCERNED. THAT OF THE GOVERNOR
MADE DISK REAL FOR. AND IT WAS
A MATTER OF. WITH IN FRACTION
OF A WE- THIS WAS SIGNED. AND
WE WANTED TO KNOW. HOW THE TWO
INTERACTED AND THERE WAS A
LIMITED IF ANY AMOUNT OF
ANALYSIS DONE IT WAS JUST
BASICALLY. NO COMPLEMENT EACH
OTHER AND WE- HAD TO DO THE
SCHOOL RE OPENING PROPOSAL
WITHOUT KNOWING IF THERE WAS
ANY SUPPLANTING OR ANY
ASSISTANCE. OR THE STATE
FLEXIBLE FUNDS MIGHT BE USED.
AND SERVE THE THERE WAS A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF ANALYSIS. TO
PUT IT TOGETHER WITH THE STATE
BUDGET. NOW WE HAVE A MUCH
BIGGER ONE STILL A SMALL.
AMOUNT OF ST FLEXIBLE FUNDS IN
THE IN THE ROLE OF AN AMOUNT.
BUT MY QUESTION IS WILL THERE
BE A AND I HEARD CLEARLY THAT
WE'RE STILL WAITING FOR FEDERAL
GUIDANCE ON. SOME OF THE PIECES
OF THIS WHICH WAS THE PROBLEM
WITH THE ONE THAT CAME ABOUT
JANUARY FIRST AS WELL. FROM IS
THERE GOING TO BE ANALYSIS.
THAT TELLS US HOW THIS FITS TO
THE STATE BUDGET AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING TO SCHOOLS TO THE
STATE BUDGET. THE PANEL ALL
START WITH OF THE L. A. R. WHEN
AND IF THERE IS- FINANCE
COMMENT I WOULD APPRECIATE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR LARRY I THINK THAT IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION
AND ADDS SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
REPEATEDLY KIND OF- EXPRESSED
TO THE LEGISLATURE HOW TO
DISPENSE THESE FEDERAL FRIENDS
AT AND AS IN A WAY THAT
COMPLIMENTS. HOW THE STATE IS
SPENDING OTHER AT. C. GENERAL
FUND FOR PROMOTING LEARNING
LOSS ECOVERY OR SCHOOL RE
OPENING I THINK THE CHALLENGING
THING IS EXPENDITURE DATA MOST
LIKELY WON'T BE AVAILABLE FOR
ITS THAT AFTER FUNDS I HAVE
ALREADY GONE OUT AND SO NOT
ENTIRELY- SURE WE'RE ABLE TO DO
A THOROUGH ANALYSIS ON WHETHER
OR NOT- SEAT FUNDS PROVIDED FOR
AND THESE THESE PRIORITIES HAVE
BEEN SOME PLANTING- BE SEVERAL
TIMES. I DON'T KNOW IF AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WITH ONE
AWAY IN ON THAT ANYMORE. LET ME
ASK IF THERE'S ANY HERE COMES
MELISSA HANG ON TO OUR SCREENS
SO. WOULD YOU LIKE TO A COMMENT
ON THAT. SURE SO WE ARE WORKING
WITH PLEDGE STAFF AND
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE KEEPING IN
MIND FOR ALL GUIDELINES AS WE
BUILD AND- BUILD ALL THESE
FUNDS INTO THE MAY REVISION.
LATTICED CAN'T REALLY SPEAK TO
KIND OF THE DETAILS ON- AROUND
ANY OF THE PROPOSALS. KAY WHAT
I'M GOING TO. TAKE FROM THAT IS-
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON IT IN
DEBT I JUST WANT US STATE
REALLY CLEARLY. THAT WE HAVE
THAT CONCERN WE WANT TO BE
INVOLVED WE WANT TO KNOW HOW IT
FITS TOGETHER TO THE EXTENT WE
HAVE SPENDING INFORMATION
LOOKING BACK WOULD LIKE IT.
LOOKING FORWARD TO KNOW BEFORE
WE DO ANYTHING WITH THE
FLEXIBLE FUNDS. HOW EVERYTHING
FITS TOGETHER WILL BE IN A VERY
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION FOR US
AND SO I JUST WANT TO RESTATE
THAT SO THAT IT'S NOT A
SURPRISE AND- IT. IF SOMETHING
COMES BACK TO WEST THAT DOESN'T
HAVE THAT BUT- A PROJECTS
EXPENDITURE OF THE FUNDS BE
PREPARED TO HIDE UNDER YOUR
DESK- BUT I JUST WANT TO PUT
THAT OUT THERE BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION- SENATOR BOGEY
HAS NO QUESTIONS. DISINTERMENT
HAVE A QUESTION YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO FOLLOW UP ON THE
CHAIRMAN LAERTES- POINT HERE-
IF I'M RECALLING CORRECTLY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET- HAS
SIGNIFICANT FUNDS ALLOCATED FOR
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION MENTAL
HEALTH- AND THEN ALSO
EMPHASIZE- HELLO A LOW INCOME
AND DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND
I THINK THOSE ARE ALL IMPORTANT
PRIORITIES BUT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND IS VERY STIMULUS PACKAGES
INCLUDING THE A. R. P. R. I.
TRYING TO COVER THE SAME BASIS
THAT THAT WE ARE BEING FLEXIBLE
WITH THE BUDGET THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FOLLOW IT IN THE
WORDS OF A- PREVIOUS WITNESS.
MAXIMIZING OUR FEDERAL DOLLARS
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE THAT
THAT SHOULD BE PRINCIPLE HERE
AS WE ADAPT OUR BUDGET TO WHAT
THE SIGNIFICANT FUNDS COMING IN
FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S NOT REALLY A QUESTION SO
MUCH AS A COMMENT BUT JUST
WANTED TO. FIVE ECHO IN SECOND
GERMAN LETTERS POINT. THAT IS
NOTED AND THE LESS I SEE A HAND.
WE'RE GONNA I HOPE SAY WE'RE
DONE WITH THIS ITEM SO- LET ME
THANK THE PANELISTS WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE- THIS
IS REALLY BEEN A HELPFUL
SESSION AND NOW THE ONE
REMAINING ITEM WE HAVE IS TO GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR ANYBODY TO
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE ITEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN HERE AND WE'LL
START OUT WITH A ONE MINUTE
LIMITATION OF BUT IF IT TURNS
OUT THAT WE HAVE A LOT IN THE
QUEUE. BOB HOPE WE MIGHT CUT
THAT DOWN SO WHAT'S THE TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
844-291-4185 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
THREE THREE EIGHT ZERO FOUR SIX
SEVEN AND MODERATOR ARE YOU
WITH US. HELLO MISTER CHAIR I
AM GREAT- DO WE HAVE ANYBODY
QUEUED UP. FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
WISH TO COMMENT AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PRESS ONE MIN ZERO PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIR WE
DO HAVE A FEW PEOPLE OF
SIGNALED THAT THEY WISH TO
SPEAK WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
MINE THIRTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EMILY ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU
CORPORATION THE CONVERSATION ON
THE ONLY CHRISTIAN AND WE URGE
AB. AND IT TO UNIVERSAL IT IS
REALLY HELPFUL NOT ONLY FOR
KIDS NOT TO WORRY ABOUT WHETHER
MEAL COMING FROM IN ABOUT
CRITICISM THEIR PEERS BUT ALSO
FOR OUR CLASS BY WORKERS IN OUR
COUNTRY WORKERS NOT TO HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT GOING OUT KIDS ARE
NOT PROVIDING THEM WITH MEALS
WHEN THEY- OFTEN STRUGGLE WITH
HUNGER. ADDITIONALLY ON ISSUE
FOR WOULD LIKE FOR
CONSIDERATION- FUNNY TO ME THAT
I CAN'T TO CLEANING DOLLARS WE
HAVE NOT HAD DOLLARS DEDICATED
TO DALY AND PREVENTIVE
STAFFING- FOR CLEANING THEY'VE
BEEN CUT TWO THOUSAND- AND WE
HAVE THE WILLIAMS CASE AND THEN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT BACK BUT
REDUCED. FURTHER WE ACTUALLY
HAVE LEFT BACK TODAY THEN WE
DID BACK IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
AND EVEN WORSE IN TWO THOUSAND
AND WOULD REALLY URGE THAT
DEDICATED FUNDING TO ENSURE
THAT OUR SCHOOLS ARE SAFE AND
CLEAN THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. IT WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO- BY. SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU WANT TO TAKE
OFF I THINK ONE TO SHARE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS JERRY
CALL IN L. MY COMMENTS IN THE
BOOK SHE WANTS NUTRITION SHOULD
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
CONSIDERING THE PROPOSAL TO
MAKE RECORDS AND LUNCH FREE OF
CHARGE ALL STUDENTS ACROSS OUR
STATE. UNIVERSAL MEAL THE GOAL
WE GET NURSE CALIFORNIA. HAVE
LONG ADVOCATED. WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE MORE. NAY TO REACH A
CHILDREN RISK WILL THING WE
URGE THE TO CONSIDER AS PART OF
A MUCH NEEDED UNIVERSAL MEAL
SOLUTION MAKING STATE
INVESTMENT TO MAXIMIZE THE
COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY
PROVISION. ET TO ALLOW MORE
SCHOOL OPERATE THE HE AWAY
THAT. ARE WEAKER ANIMAL. YEAH
PREVIOUS BAILABLE EQUITABLE IN
OF STATE ALL THAT WILL BE MORE
THAN. FEDERAL YEAH THIS YEAR
CAN MATCH MICROSD DOLLARS WHILE
ENSURING THE KIDS GET PRETTY
COLD WELL. READY TO LEARN AND
ABLE TO FOR PEOPLE TO THRIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MODERATOR NEXT CALL. WHY TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KATIE HARDY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION JUST WANTED TO MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT ON ISSUE ONE TO
KEEP THE COURTS EXPANDING THE
SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAM AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION TODAY THANKS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR COMMENT. BLIND TWENTY TWO
THE LINE IS OPEN. MMHM ONE
TWENTY LIKE TWENTY TWO YEAR ONE
IS OPEN HE MAY BE VOTED THANK
YOU HI JESSICA SOCCER ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW- I DON'T
REGARDING ITEM ONE I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION ON
THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC ONE ISSUE
THAT WAS ALLUDED TO THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO ELEVATE IS THAT
TRADITIONALLY DISTRICTS HAVE
COLLECTED FAMILY INCOME DATA
FOR THE FEDERAL PROGRAM TO
DETERMINE STUDENTS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FREE OR REDUCED
MEALS AND THEN USE THAT SAME
DATA TWICE ENOUGH I DIDN'T.
LOOK CONSIDERED SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED FOR
LCS APPLICATION REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT TO CONFIRM
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEALS IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE THEM HAS REDUCED
PARTICIPATION AND THIS DATA
COLLECTION RESULTING IN A
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTION IN COUPLE
MENTAL AND CONCENTRATION GRANT
FUNDS ALLOCATED TO DISTRICTS
THEREFORE WE URGE YOU TO
IMPLEMENT A HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISION FOR UNDUPLICATED
PUPIL COUNT FOR THE CURRENT. AS
WELL AS THE COMING SCHOOL YEAR.
BY THE WAY TO EXAMPLE. LAST OR
IF ME DURING CURRENT YEAR IS
ESTIMATES. READ IN THE LOSS OF
AROUND THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION CHEN LC ABOUT
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
GRANTS FUND. REGARDING ITEM FOR
ANY AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN FUND
WE STRONGLY URGE THE- COMMITTEE
CONSIDER HOW FUNDS MAY BE USED
TO DIRECTLY SUPPORT. COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
WHO ARE PROVIDING SUPPORT. FOR
EXTENDED LEARNING. AND A
SUPPLEMENTAL INSTRUCTIONAL
TIME. AS DOES DOES PROGRAMS ARE
KNOWN TO BE ENGAGING AND
ENRICHING AND SHOULDN'T LIVES
AND HAVE SPECIALIZED IN- A
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL LEARNING. THEY HAVE
NOT BEEN THE RECIPIENT OF
DIRECT SUPPORT AND FUNDING- IN
A WAY THAT HELPS THEM UNIQUELY
ENGAGING SUPPORT STUDENTS.
DURING THIS TIME IN ADDITION-
THE A. R. P. FUNDS DO COME WITH
A REQUIREMET THAT HE STATE
DEVELOP A PLAN INCLUDING
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT- AND YET
THAT HAS NOT TAKEN PLACE AND
WE- URGE THE- THAT WOULD. YOU
CONSIDER HOW YOU MIGHT
STRENGTHENED REPORTING.
REQUIREMENTS ON HOW FUNDS ARE
SPENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU MUCH
FOR YOUR CALL. LINE. TWENTY
FOUR. I REMEMBER THIS FIRST
OPTION POLICY OPTIONS AND LONG
WELCOME TO COMPLEMENT MY CALL.
OR SCHOOL OUR SCHOOL MEALS FOR
ALL CHILDREN THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD HELP ON COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR MORE SPECIFICALLY. BLACK
AND BROWN. AND ARE GIVEN THE
BARRIERS THAT MANY OF OUR THE-
BOTH BOGEYS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND AGAIN WE WOULD LIKE
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO COMMENT AT
THIS TIME THE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BUTTON ZERO PRESS ONE AND ZERO
WE NOW GOING TO GO TO LINE
TWENTY THREE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS TERAFLOPS I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CANNERY INDUSTRY LABOR
MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEE A LONG NAME FOR A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN UNION
CANNERY WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS.
AND I'M HERE ON ITEM ONE I
ACTUALLY WANTED TO ECHO- EVEN
THAT WAS MADE BY THE SPEAKER
FROM THE FOOD BANK ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF- SCHOOL MEALS
UNIVERSAL SCHOOL MEALS. IN
CREATING GOOD JOBS AND HEALTHY
HIGH QUALITY FOOD WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT THAT NOTION- SCHOOL
MEALS. BYE BY CALIFORNIA
PROCESSOR UNION CANNERY WORKERS
AND WE WANTED TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THE FEDERAL SCHOOL MEAL PROGRAM
HAS MADE IN THE- USA BY
AMERICAN THAT PROVISIONS THAT
ARE SO IMPORTANT TO WORKERS IN
THE CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY UNITED
CANNERY WORKERS- SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS. LINE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS PART OF AN OLD
FRIEND COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF FREE SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR IT APPEARS THAT WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE TODAY WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT. AND- NO COMMENTS
FROM SENATORS SO LET ME JUST
THANK ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CRITICIZE. IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY YOU CAN SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE. OR YOU
CAN VISIT THE WEBSITE ARE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN AN
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND WE APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WITH THE HEARING.
WE'VE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BE MEETING
WEDNESDAY AND THURSDAY OF NEXT
WEEK AND THEN THE MAY REVISE
WILL COME SO THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE STANDS ADJOURNED.